Le us oh of
course okay we have some members who are
at a county meeting who will be here uh
hopefully shortly we have a couple fa
Fresh Faces who missed our first meeting
and we'll give you some time to
afternoon to uh introduce yourselves
when uh when the other folks are here so
we'll do that this afternoon all right
first up uh is hb220 relative to
transferring statutory Authority from
the Department of Education to the
Department of military Affairs in
veteran services
regarding educational Support Services
the uh Prime sponsor is here
representative kraton uh welcome welcome
sir
thank you Mr chair appreciate the time
this
morning fellow Representatives I'm here
to introduce hb20 an act relative to
transferring statutary Authority from
Department of Education to the
Department of military Affairs and
veteran services when the department of
military Affairs and veteran services
was stood up along with it came a series
of uh authorities and responsibilities
but not necessarily the statutes that
support that what this bill does is it
transfers the statutory requirement from
the Department of Education to the
Department of military Affairs
essentially they're doing the job now
they've got a team that's already been
hired and they're you know finding out
which schools for working out in tuition
assistance doing all those things that
had been under Department of Education
they're doing it what's missing is a
statutory authority to do that and so
what this bill does is it basically
updates the statutes so that what the
department it does is in line the
Department of Education is completely on
board with this and agrees to it uh as
is the as is the Department of military
so it's fairly straightforward subject
to any questions uh I appreciate your
support uh thank you representative so
what I'm hearing is uh this would Cod y
a de facto ongoing situation exactly
that's been to agreed to by both
departments check questions for the
prime sponsor on
this uh well thank you sir thank you sir
that was one of the smoothest
introductions I have ever witnessed uh I
we do have some pink cards uh Brent
Brent Fraser is here
welcome back Mr Fraser and also
um uh Ste Steve uh applebe is is in the
house as well uh Co co-chairs so to
speak uh I don't know who'll start uh I
guess Brent's name was first covered up
and then Steve well thank you thank you
sir uh committee members good morning
and thanks for having us uh it is good
to be back here after our session last
week and as you stated uh Department of
Education uh and Department of military
Affairs and veteran services uh we've
been together from the beginning they've
helped us establish and implement the
program and uh we just wanted to share
that uh as was representative kraton
mentioned that this is really just
codification of what is currently being
executed as we speak uh as of January
2024 uh Department of military Affairs
and veteran services uh entered into an
agreement with the US Department of
Veterans Affairs uh and accepted the
responsibility for the state approving
agency uh it's responsible for reviewing
and evaluating and approving educational
and training programs for veterans who
use their VA benefits uh it ensures
educational programs meet Federal
criteria uh provides assistance to
schools and training facilities either
that are seeking approval or who already
approved and must be
reapproved um it's a 100% federally
funded program uh no General funds are
required uh and as such there's no
fiscal impact to the the general fund uh
budget so sumary Department of military
Affairs and Veterans Services uh
supports this bill uh as part of the
overarching consolidation of uh veteran
services under the department uh and
thank you for your continued support of
service members veterans and their
families and with that sir I would uh
turn it over to Mr applebe if he has any
comments thank you and thank you Mr
chair and Committee Member Steve applebe
Department of Education uh director of
educator support and higher ed uh we of
course support this as well uh it just
makes so much more sense for our veteran
population to have a One-Stop shop um
and additionally they already have
significant ties to the Federal
Department of Veterans Affairs that we
just don't have at the department of EDS
so it really made a lot of sense to make
the move so and exactly as as the
Director said it's just codifying what's
already in
place thank you both the Optics of the
two of you sitting together uh conveys
that you're in sync at least to me
anyway uh questions for either gentleman
uh yes uh representative
budak uh thank you chair
so um Department of military Affairs and
V Affairs have been doing this uh work
before
codification right that is that is
correct we entered into a Cooperative
agreement with the VA uh about a year
ago and we've been executing since
January of
2024 follow up Sir follow
up has this kind of Bill uh was
introduced in this uh chamber before or
not uh not to my knowledge I don't
believe so no
sir thank you Mr
chair other
questions seeing none thank you both we
have one more card here from um Kevin
Grady Mr Grady from um uh State veterans
advisory committee sfac welcome back Mr
Grady thank you very much uh Mr chair
ladies and gentlemen of the committee
once again for the record my name is
Kevin Grady I'm a 25y year Air Force
veteran and a 27-year resident of the
town of hooks at New Hampshire uh we and
the state veterans advisory committee
wholeheartedly support this bill if
you'll recall the um the story that I
told you when we were here for
orientation about how the governor asked
us what uh you know if he had a problem
with a veteran where do I send him and
we said well the answer is probably in
this room but we don't we don't have a
specific belly button and that
ultimately led to the standup of the
Department of military Affairs and
veteran services when that happened
about five years ago we kind of realized
that there would be pockets of people
out there in the government system doing
things for our veterans that that we
missed the first time around and we've
just got to return them to the fold so
it makes sense to all of us for One-Stop
shopping for them to go to dmas for this
and we fully support this bill subject
to your questions I am all
done thank you Mr Grady
questions uh a quick comment I want to
thank you again you mentioned uh our
session last week uh we spent the whole
morning with an orientation and several
people have watched that on YouTube and
um uh very impressed with uh all the
different pieces of the veterans
community uh support uh resource that
are out there including svac so uh thank
you for being here last week and for
your testimony
today seeing no questions uh thank you
again thank you
sir we have no other pink
cards so I will at this
time close the hearing on
hb10 uh next up at 950 is uh hb10 2 uh
which has a fiscal note um the uh
representative from antrum is also the
co-sponsor on that uh we have a rule in
the
house that we um cannot start early um
some of you know that and uh we were so
efficient with hb220 which is quite rare
so now we have uh a little over five
minutes uh to that we we have to wait
so um given that we have this time uh
I'd like to ask uh the new
representative represent Bennett let's
let's do this anyway soon we have time
could you uh take a couple minutes and
just uh you were not able to be here the
first day if you could just tell us a
little bit uh we know who you are but
where you're from and a little bit about
your
journey okay okay great so my name is
Cindy Bennett I'm from Raymond New
Hampshire
and yeah I this is my first time into
this building so it's was
quite um interesting
and uh
just exciting I guess you'd say um I'm a
mother of 13 I've homeschooled I've um
I'm also a teacher um I have a sub today
um
so I work at a private Christian School
in New Hampshire as well and uh
so we just did all the things this
summer to get elected and here I am and
I'm new so thank you for um I I feel
really um honored to be here so thank
you thank you representative so 13
children is's some um some signholders
for your campaign I'm I'm wondering
unfortunately they're all grown up now
my youngest is 17 so they're kind of
like spreading out and uh I am on the
school board in my town I didn't mention
that and a couple other boards so I do
work in the town so um I didn't come
fresh out of you know
housework to here but um yeah it would
be nice if my when my kids were younger
if I had done it then then I could had a
lot of sign holders but unfortunately
they're kind of you you know kind of
doing their own thing and that's the
thing
they they which is kind of good you know
they've found their own way I do have
one son who was in the Army and he's now
um benefiting he's almost done with his
um college degree so that's very
interesting to me that he was able to do
that he wanted to serve in the Army like
the Grassroots type of thing and he
uh he did he lives in Georgia now
though thank thank you
again uh welcome aboard and uh when I
mentioned the signold I was being a
little bit uh a little bit cheeky not
you can't always assume that U is most
of most of us who are parents know so
well not not all of our offspring would
necessarily hold our signs uh but uh so
I I I know that too uh so also uh a
fresh face who is not able to be here
for orientation is the representative
from hookit uh represent plant U Can you
tell us a little bit about you and your
journey absolutely thank you Mr chair um
so my name is Ray plant first term uh
representative uh I actually live in the
town of Dunbarton but I represent in a
flal district with Dunbarton hooks at
Allenstown in Epsom um I am a veteran
myself uh currently serving the Vermont
Army National Guard uh been in for 19
years now I'm the Brigade Aviation
officer for the ad six infantry Brigade
combat team um full-time still working
as well uh fly for Jet Blue out of
Boston so I'm all over the place all the
time um I think I was in Florida last
Friday with our first meeting um but now
that I know the schedule I should be
here going forward I'm happy to be here
uh VA rated as well so I'm intimately
familiar with the the VA healthare
system and our wonderful facility in
Manchester uh that's about all I
have thank you representative it's good
to see you and also representative
Hemingway maintaining those military
haircuts um I uh I did get a haircut
before the inaugural ball I don't get
them every week like I used to but uh
who does uh but apparently you do so
anyway uh welcome aboard it's a naval
term of course but glad glad you're here
and
uh it's still not quite
950 the representative from londondary
is is uh not new to this committee but
he he missed the orientation repres of L
could you uh let the hundreds of people
watching online um sure I checked we had
like four or 500 watch next week so it's
been a pleasure I I believe uh it's my
eighth term or seventh term skip would
you did we start together yeah seven all
right we're starting our seventh term uh
I've been on this committee uh since day
one uh absolutely enjoy it uh we have a
wonderful chair and
co-chair um I'm a chiropractor in
Londoner uh I have the opportunity to
treat a lot of veterans uh through the
uh Veterans Affairs um uh recommendation
uh I uh side note I I proposed an opioid
Bill uh and five years ago I actually
met with the secretary the VA in
Washington about it and he was very
excited about it and uh
uh he asked me if he would uh be able to
send it around to the vas in the country
and I thought well he's blowing smoke
but uh within a week I get a call from
the administrator and we sat down and uh
it's moving forward
um uh I've been a chiropractor 48 years
I know I don't look that uh but it's a
it's really a pleasure and an honor to
be able to serve as a representative
from Londoner and to serve in this
committee this committee is very very
important uh and uh I'm really glad to
see what we are able to do for the
Vets um I'm not one but I I've always
honored that so I guess that's about it
and thank you
for having me speak and thank you for
your service representative seven terms
uh that almost
you almost have tenure uh you know with
all those terms glad you're back glad
glad that you're
here and uh we have two clocks in this
room one of them is ahead of the other
one I'm going to go with the clock that
says 0950 hours so that we can uh not
break any rules so there it is uh 9 0950
so I'd like to welcome back the uh the
representative from antrum um who was
the Prime sponsor of hp120 also the
prime sponsor of HB
122 uh which is an act relative to
payment of claims arising out of actions
or activities of the New Hampshire
National Guard uh welcome back
representative thank you sir for the
record I'm Jim kraton representative
Hillsboro District 30 I'm here to
introduce House Bill
um typically when a National Guard goes
out they do a great job they you know
they're all through the north coning our
search and rescue they're on on the
roads they're in towns sometimes they
might hit a
mailbox sometimes a helicopter might
land in a field and knock over a fence
that happens uh the rules are today that
the National Guard can pay out 500 bucks
say here's 500 bucks here's a new
mailbox it doesn't have to go through
the courts it doesn't have to go through
litigation it doesn't have to it's just
hey we screwed up we'll pay for your new
mailbox um when I talked to National
Guard Bureau they said that that $500
was established sometime prior to the
Civil War or something of that nature it
hasn't been updated in a long long time
and so what this bill does is it says
hey uh you can't get a new bail box for
1,000 bucks or for 500 bucks let's up it
to a th000 and it gives the uh
Department the authority to take care of
our citizens as they're going about
doing their daily business uh just for
context in
1983 we used to go through Germany and
we had a lieutenant in the back of the
formation and he had a bag of 20 or
$30,000 in his in his bag and he would
pay the Germans as we went through um it
was a different world a different time
but that's that's the way it's done so
this this is just um really taking care
of New Hampshire citizens that happen to
be impacted by the guard in some way
doesn't happen a lot but it would be
nice just to be a able to say here pay
for the fence and move on so subject to
your questions that's that that's what
hb22 does and uh I appreciate uh your
your support thank
you thank you representative uh I'm
aware of uh what the policy was in
Europe you described particularly in
Germany um I will share just a comment
uh with the Marines in South Korea we uh
we go barreling all over the place up
and down roads cross fields we set a
mountain on fire uh I don't know if we
had anybody following uh uh giving M
people money I wasn't concerned about
that at the time but in retrospect uh uh
you know we did put the fire out that we
started I don't I don't know if anybody
lost any property but uh uh I'm aware of
of the situation in training where
sometimes there's collateral damage and
uh I I am glad that we have something in
place to uh address that questions for
the prime sponsor uh yes uh Madam clerk
sure thank you Mr chairman so just to
clarify would this bill raise that limit
to $1,000 yes ma'am it it takes it from
500 to 1,000 all right um followup good
question and followup
so does the bill set some regulations
around um reimbursement for the the
original value of the property item I'm
just wondering you know someone could
have a damaged mailbox but it's one of
those plastic ones you can pick up from
Home Depot and then they may come to you
and say my mailbox was damaged I would
like a nice Granite one yes ma'am um
short answer is this bill does not okay
all this bill does is change 500 to
1,000 okay the rules regulations
associated with fair value and all that
are already existent okay and this just
says hey 500 isn't enough let's give the
department a th000 all right thank you
for
clarifying representative is there an
appeal process if a if there's a $10,000
mailbox or what
whatever uh U and the the homeowner that
has the damage does thinks that the
damage incurred was greater than $1,000
is is it a repeal process yeah yes sir
there is um and that's already existent
and so if it if the claim goes above
today $500 then it goes through a
totally separate process which is a
legal process for claims and
reimbursement thank thank you other
questions uh representative Rollins yes
thank you for taking my question if I
remember correctly there was an incident
with National Guard training I believe
in a field a snowmobile that came around
a corner too fast clipped one of the
helicopters and he suing does that
pertain to this or is that is this
lawsuit something separate than what
we're looking no this is completely
separate so that that would be a lawsuit
through the legal program this is an
administrative action which is just a
claim that goes and says hey you guys
broke my mailbox if if the snowm broke
the helicopter then that's the other way
around and that's completely
different thank you good
question other
questions sing none thank you uh to the
prime sponsor uh we have in the house
again uh she was here last week Deputy
agitant General Nicole deset Bixler
welcome
back thank you Mr chairman and members
of the committee um just as
representative representative kraton
just uh outlined this really just lifts
the limit the limit was placed at 500 in
1981 under RSA 110b 73 so that was a
long time ago so what we're trying to do
is keep up with inflationary costs um
and also we are cleaning up the language
which is very
minor which refers to the Department of
agitant general which has changed as of
2019 to the Department of military
Affairs and veteran services so really
what we're doing by raising the limit to
a th000 is we could have payments out in
approximately 2 weeks for these small
claims whereas the board of claims
appeal and all of that the whole legal
process that comes with the board of
claims process if it's over $1,000 can
take months so that's the difference we
can pay it out quickly for a small claim
I gave a couple of examples in my
written testimony um but that's that's
really the gist of it thank you for
allowing me to speak and do you have any
questions uh represent mental bomb uh
thank you Mr chairman uh you mentioned
Britain testimony would you be able to
provide that to us yes I I did already
should I make copies and send again or
have a copy of that I I don't have a
copy of the written testimony did you
submit it via uh the via email okay
about a week ago okay I'm sure but I can
provide it again and I I'll email all
the members of the committee if you'd
like sir well we don't ask you to do
that twice uh we'll look for that but if
as a back I do have a copy of it right
now but it's just one copy would you
like it sir the clerk always likes to
file a hard copy okay and um and we will
uh we will find uh we we'll check the
email so that everybody can review that
um sir I can provide that right now uh
if you if you didn't mind I don't mind
sir we our clerk keeps a file and again
one hard copy is always good of course
we have the electronic testimony as well
uh thank you for that uh any other
questions uh
representative uh
bataki um thank you Mr chair I just want
to understand more about this because
we're talking about raising money from
$500 to
$1,000 so who's going to pay this money
sir that would come out of the budget
for the Department of military Affairs
and veteran services so we feel that we
could absorb this in our budget this
happens very rarely when I talk to our
budget officer who's been in that
position for 25 years she said only two
times this would have applied in that
period of time and the and the total
would have only been a thousand but it
was more than in those two incidents
were more than the $500 so we had to go
through the board of claims appeals um
and appeals process
M followup quick certainly uh followup
so we are not making this money from our
budget from state budget money is coming
from the federal
government no sir it's not coming from
it's coming from the Department of
military Affairs and and veteran
services budget which is our state
budget yes as I understand your good
question about where the money comes
from the uh
it it's from the guard's budget and and
the the total guard budget uh is a
function of both uh State support and
federal support um is that fair to say
so as yes sir so we have we have a state
budget and this would come out of our
state budget this is not 100% federally
reimbursable this this comes out of our
state budget and we feel that we could
absorb that cost uh and that's why the
fiscal note is there too that you know I
I when I went over the fiscal note this
is before I've been in this position for
about two weeks and three days and five
hours I'm just kidding but uh the fiscal
note uh was done prior was done uh in
2024 and it says that for fiscal years
2025 through
2028 um the fiscal impact would be less
than
$10,000 um I think it would be even less
than that I don't think that very many
claims would fall under the ,000 limit
um however if it did and then that's
small enough that we feel that we could
absorb that with our state
budget does the guard have a line item
for this for this uh for this funding or
is it would it come from a general fund
type situation sir I believe it would
come from the general fund but I can
check with my budgetary
office okay thank you I mean the the
thought then would be if it was a line
item and it was not and there was no
damage done would would the line item
roll over or or we would request it the
next for the next bial budget yes sir we
would but I honestly sir I don't know if
we have a line item for this but I can
check with my budget
officer okay if that wasn't too much of
a it seems that did come up as as a fair
question if uh if if someone could shoot
yes sir I'll I'll get back with you on
that get back to you and the members of
the committee would be just a little bit
smarter that's why we have these
hearings sure absolutely uh rup Manion
yeah I think just to piggyback on that
if it goes through the claims process
you're still paying that anyway right so
if it goes beyond the $500 currently
right now you're still out of you're
still paying the same money this just
allows for an administrative action to
be a lot quicker correct yes sir all
right thank you other
questions Cena thank you uh to the
deputy agitant General thank you Mr
Kevin Grady is still here and we have a
uh a card from him to uh speak in
support of hb1 1222 uh welcome back Mr
Grady thank you Mr chair ladies and
gentlemen of the committee once again
for the record uh my name is Kevin Grady
I'm a 25y year Air Force veteran and a
27y year resident of the town of hookit
New Hampshire uh the
svac supports this bill uh periodically
things need an update you know I I I
have a a saying I use a lot with my
friends when they discover something
that um everybody else has been doing
for like a decade or so you know like
they say hey I just discovered I can pay
all my bills online well welcome to the
20th century well that's kind of where
we are here this thing hasn't been this
thing hasn't been updated since the
before the 20th century so it's time to
uh to realize that things cost more and
and and this is a a small price to pay
for those people that might fall within
that $500 to $1,000 window that to not
have to go through the claims process so
we support this legislation that's all I
wanted to tell you esvac is in favor any
questions for Mr
Grady C thank you for your testimony
thank
you and having no more pin cards we
will calling n to the hearing on hb12 FN
uh we still have a few minutes before uh
1010 um
again a very efficient uh and
unusual uh uh hearing process this
morning uh so we'll wait uh just a
little bit and then we will um ask the
representative from mantrum to uh come
back up again to introduce hp64 in uh
just a couple
minutes in the interest of using our
time to the best
extent possible um we have a c this is
for uh hp64
okay
um you you'll be back right okay all
right we get we got uh a couple more
minutes before we we can start yes we're
using the fast
clock
e
e e
okay we do have two clocks in here we
have a slow clock and a fast clock and
the uh as I see the fast clock which is
when I'm going by it's uh approaching
1010 and so uh with that uh I will uh
call the uh hearing to
order we or we'll start the hearing on H
B 1064 that is an act relative to
extending hiring preferences for
military members and their spouses to
the state and private businesses and
establishing purchase preferences for
disabled veterans and Military spouses
regarding State Supply
purchases uh the prime sponsor is uh
representative Roy who is
here uh
representative kraton is two for two uh
and he's on deck uh it's good to have
backup in the in the military it's
called a reserve uh an active reserve a
mobile Reserve uh welcome representative
Roy welcome thank you Mr chairman
members of the committee my name is
representative Terry Roy um I represent
Rockingham 32 I am here introducing
House Bill 64 um the need for this bill
was brought to my attention by the
Department of Defense
um this is a very important move that we
can make to help our active duty and
their family um feel welcome comfortable
and help them Thrive within our state
and helping them establish businesses
and giving them the same preferences
that we here to have given to active
duty or or veterans is going to help
them establish and hopefully grow their
businesses and stay in our state when
their commitment to the military is
finished as well so I'm going to let the
Department of Defense explain to you the
minutia of the bill and why they feel
it's necessary but I hope you will give
it your consideration and support and um
I'll take any questions you want but I I
think that they would be better suited
to answer
them thank you represent I do want to
throw one at you as the prime sponsor
the uh description of the ACT uh the the
expression hiring preference preference
is there uh and I I think we all
understand what that generally what that
means but when there is a a preference
and when military folks get an advantage
uh or preference that's the word here uh
that sometimes can be perceived as at
the expense of of someone else uh so
that's a question that I think uh is
likely on the minds of some of the folks
watching at home or or some of the
committee members and we can uh ask
about that to some of the subsequence uh
testifiers but uh do you have any
concern that uh preferential treatment
for veterans could be um uh unfair to
other people I I don't know if that's an
issue but but uh in terms of preferences
that that's something that uh I think
we'd like you to address sure I would be
happy to I'll give you my my personal uh
take on that
um preferences when looked at in General
would mean that someone's treated
differently or better than someone else
for no
reason the people that we talking about
extending a preference to are people
that that we owe a debt to we we can't
pay um we don't there's not enough money
to pay for someone's lost love life
fortunes that they sacrific by serving
in the military family members um move
around the world in the country with
their loved ones all in defense of our
Liberty and
freedom I feel that a small gesture of
op giving them an opportunity to have a
job or a business within our state is is
a is a thank you that we can extend to
them that doesn't cost us anything and
as far as the ability to obtain that
preference um we have a volunteer
military and anyone is available to join
it and risk their lives and their
fortunes and thereby gain that
preference for themselves as well so
it's not something that people are given
by Birthright or by their nationality or
color of their skin or religion they
have to earn it and they have to put
something on the line to get that
preference so I would say that that
would be my response to that thank you
for that any other questions for the
prime sponsor reps of mandle bomb thank
you Mr chairman so this might be getting
a bit technical but when it comes to
preferences for disabled veterans and
Military spouses when it comes to state
purchases where would that preference
for those people fall in relation to the
cost of those goods or services I I
would I'll I'll I'll haard to guess but
please take what they say the dod says
above what I say and if it contradicts
they're right and I'm wrong um I would
say that we would not take a more
expensive um contract over a more
efficient one simply because the person
has that preference I think looking at
it it would be all things being equal
the preference should go to the veteran
spouse or the veteran versus well the
state will have to spend an extra
million but that's a veteran no all
right thank
you other
questions uh representative plan thank
you Mr chair just to clarify this bill
doesn't touch on uh purchases and
preference of who who gets allocated um
a contract to bid on something this is
simply
expanding already existing law to
include military spouses for hiring of
positions where they would go to work
yeah that's correct the current bidding
process is open to everyone and no one
would get preference as far as who's
allowed to bid on on things thank
you other
questions Cena thank you to the prime
sponsor thank you to the committee the
representative from antrum is still in
the house uh representative kraton uh do
you want to add anything okay uh
represent kraton uh co-sponsor passes uh
Mr Fraser is is still here uh Brent
Fraser from New Hampshire D
Mavs welcome back Mr chair community
members it is good to be here for the
record Brent Frasier director of
communitybased military programs from
the Department of military Affairs and
veteran
services uh sir uh with respect to uh HB
64 relative to extending hiring
preferences and Military members and
their sponsors to the state and private
businesses as well as the purchase
preferences for disabled veterans and
Military spouses the department supports
this legislation uh the bill expands the
definitions for Veterans for the
purposes of veterans hiring uh
employment preferences to include the
veteran spouse and active duty service
members as as well um of the 85,000 or
so veterans in the state
uh most are doing very well they make up
about 6% of the population uh well over
the majority are employed approximately
70% are making $50,000 or more most own
their own
houses uh and are doing well but there
are some areas that they're economically
challenged uh and we feel this would
positively impact their households
veterans unemployment rates are are
slightly lower
uh than the state's average uh veterans
earn about 7% less than the New
Hampshire median income uh approximately
5% of veterans in the State live in
poverty uh and about any given time
across the state about 150 veterans may
be homeless uh this B Bill helps set
conditions for at least achieving A
Little More Level Playing Field uh both
in terms of spouses in an extreme L
competitive New Hampshire Job Market and
broadly contributes to the Department of
defense's efforts through the defense
State leaon effort to identify and
address the most pressing needs of this
is one towards military spouse
employment and economic opportunities
and I believe you have written testimony
from the defense State liaison and
perhaps maybe some uh testimony later
this morning on on that effort um and in
the event that the spouse is female and
the secondary beneficiary of the outcome
uh includes addressing the gender gap
recent Studies have shown that in New
Hampshire uh we are currently listed as
the the second highest gender gap in the
nation and this would contribute towards
addressing that situation uh this effort
also reinforces the New Hampshire
veteran friendly business Network's
efforts as we work with them to
encourage their uh recruiting and
retention of veterans across the state
it supports the New Hampshire Department
of military Affairs and Veteran Services
livefree chws New Hampshire efforts
where we reach out across the globe to
service members who are selecting to
return to the state uh and it provides
as was mentioned or implied earlier uh a
little more than just to thank you for
your service but provide some actionable
measures uh that contribute to service
members and their spouses well-being
there is some language uh in the LSR
that we would like to work with the
sponsor on lines 16 through 19 that
reflect uh a position of for the agitant
general perhaps to to do some uh
oversight and management so we'd like to
work with the sponsors there to to
address the specifics on that we're not
currently maned to address that but
absolutely welcome and and would look
forward to working with the sponsors to
address that going forward so in in
summary uh the sponsor's intent
increases the likelihood of Financial
Security for our transitioning service
members uh and their veterans and their
families uh and the bill sets the
conditions for improving their
well-being and at this point subject to
any questions that you have uh that
concludes Our Testimony thank you Mr
Fraser so I'm hearing that there's a
desire for some language changes and
Amendment um and that would be coming
from you or who who is going to suggest
the language sir yes the uh the the
department would work with the sponsor
to share some recommended language with
respect to uh the the agitant general
and and uh perhaps uh my position to be
able to do oversight of this program so
uh We've shared some initial thoughts
with the sponsor but we look forward to
more detailed
discussions okay uh and I see the prime
sponsor repent Roy is still here so this
measure is uh scheduled to be exact of
course we can always uh push that back
um so uh represent Roy if I could ask
you uh about the um amending language
that Mr Fraser spoke about when might
that be uh available for us to look at
and and take or get it to OS first and
then look then I'm not I'm not entirely
sure that it's necessary maybe um it I
think the part's talking about is
assigns a role of oversight to the adant
General's office and do you not report
to the adant general I do so I would
think that that the adant general has
the ability to defer whoever he wants or
assign whoever he wants to to fulfill
that role I don't think it mandates he
personally do it um so I'm hearing that
uh the language concerns that Mr Fraser
flagged are concerns that could be uh
addressed kind of through like a rules
situation implementation on the
implementation level through local
rules uh and would not necessitate a
change in the language of of
hp64 is Sir
uh with the with an
assessment uh currently ongoing uh while
I think that would address the the
specific language in in 16 through1 19
with respect to the agitant general uh
the department is not currently manned
to actually execute that we're the
agitant general to delegate that down
and so a little more discussion in terms
of the specific requirements and
processing procedures to make this
happen I'm sure it's something we could
work
through okay uh I'm going to just
request the prime sponsor uh confirm
with me uh today's a Friday like uh
early next week Monday or Tuesday at the
latest yeah uh if if there is a need for
us to uh work on some amending language
or not so that we can um if there is a
need for some language adjustment that
I'll get it done and I'll send it to you
okay great and then um we'll keep this
scheduled for exact next Friday unless
uh this should be no problem getting it
done by then okay uh any qu yes uh
representative Bennett for Mr
Fraser yes I just have a question um
could you give a scenario as to how this
would work and who this would help like
in
action no absolutely I I think I would
associate my initial thoughts with the
prime sponsor earlier when he talked
about preferences uh with respect to to
Veterans and their spouses in terms of
the sacrifices that they have made in
terms of uh the country uh in their
service and so um if you look at some of
the economic disadvantages that I
described earlier if you might imagine
one of those persons who's perhaps moved
every two to three years uh has had to
uh upend their careers and then start
over uh in a new location uh just the
ability to be able to from a a granite
State perspective share that uh that we
have a preference for military spouses
and active duty service members is a
significant help I think uh as one looks
at a service member uh who is activated
and going to deploy uh conduct
operations
overseas uh to enable them to help focus
on their mission uh it is a significant
help having done multiple operations
overseas not to have to worry about my
spouse and my family members but knowing
that they have the opportunity to be
able to continue their careers uh allows
one in the service to focus on their
mission I I was just kind of like are
you saying they're applying for a job
followup followup yes sure go ahead um
are you saying that they're applying for
a job and we're just saying we take one
over the other or are you just saying
we're looking specifically for service
members for this position or something
again I think I would associate myself
with the prime sponsor language where he
described it's it's not a a single uh
point of discussion with respect to
whether it's a hiring action or whether
it's a procurement Services uh that you
take this into consideration amongst all
things uh and then all things being
equal that the the veteran the service
member the spouse would have a
competitive advantage or at least for
consideration he said it much more
eloquently than I did though
that's a good question and it's always
helpful to have an example uh to help us
visualize the implementation of what
you're talking about yes I think the
prime sponsor addressed the my question
and our question about the preference
issue uh he addressed that very well I I
thought other
questions uh R melbon thank you Mr
chairman so um Mr Fraser you mentioned
that there are additional measures to
close the gender gap could you give one
or two examples of what that might mean
I I think my intent was to share that
this would uh contribute to closing the
the gender gap all right thank
you other questions representative Lloyd
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question um are there other
states that are already enacting this
type of
legislation or or legislative change
rather I think I would have to get you
uh do a little bit of research and share
that back with you
that's another great question we always
are interested in what other states are
doing um so if if there is anything
handy uh that you might be able to share
that that's a that's a very good
question other questions
representative Buddha Taki I'm working
on it representative thanks uh Mr chair
this is not a question but just a you
know remark um as you as this body knows
that I came here as Refugee and when I
drive you know in Manchester I see a lot
of veterans uh in the street uh and I
also heard that you know 5% of our
veterans they are under poverty level
and also uh you know some of them are
homeless so I think I feel very bad when
I see uh these conditions um and also I
think we can do much more better than
what we're doing at this time to
Veterans families thank you thank you
for that comment and that's a comment
that would be particularly useful uh in
executive session to maybe uh develop
even further
anything
else saying No Hands uh thank you Mr
Fraser well thank you sir Melissa
wette um is here welcome Melissa U
before you before Miss wette begins her
testimony if you could take a moment you
work for Department of Defense correct
and and you have like a region you still
have a region of states of which New
Hampshire is one if you could just take
a moment and explain your where your job
in in that you actually work for DOD
correct yeah yeah absolutely um so
before going into my testimony uh for
House Bill 64 I can give you a little
bit uh of a background for the
Department of Defense State liaison
office so we are a small office under
the under secretary of defense for
personnel and Readiness and we work uh
within our regions there are eight
Regional Liaisons across the country and
I work in uh New England as a dedicated
liaison and I live in New England uh
just across the border in Maine um so I
work with the six New England states uh
and stakeholders on issues of importance
to our service members and their
families uh specifically relating to
quality of life so any way the state can
enhance their laws and statutes um to
positively impact the lives of our
service members and their families those
are the policies that we advocate for um
with Governor's offices legislators uh
installation commanders and the military
departments within our respective
regions and these policy priorities
range uh from Health Care uh to child
care education spouse employment and a
few Justice related issues on our policy
priority list at the moment thank you
for that and uh to representative
Lloyd's question um from a few moments
ago uh given that you do work uh your
region includes New England several
States you you may or may not be able to
perhaps answer her question so uh we're
uh already not letting you give your
testimony we're already asking you
questions before you even given your
testimony so thank you for your
forbearance so uh so please uh what
you're it says you support the bill so
uh we're very interested in in U in how
you how you see the bill yeah absolutely
um so again my name is Melissa
um the New England region liaison at the
United States Department of Defense
State liaison office and we represent
the defense department and established
relationships with State leaders across
the country who are concerned with uh
service members and their families
Welfare by enhancing state laws and
regulations on policy problems of
national significance The propo Proposal
before you has the opportunity to create
stronger Pathways to employment for
military spouses and help address a
unique challenge faced by our military
families due to the high demands of
military service a majority of our
families relocate to a new Duty station
every 2 to 3 years these rapid rates of
relocation often hinder the employment
and career potential of military spouses
which in turn have long-term
consequences for both the spouse and the
family in a 2021 Department of Defense
survey of active duty spouses
48% of respondents stated that finding
employment was one of the most critical
problems they experience during
permanent change of station moves undue
stress stress whether Financial or other
has potential to disrupt the overall
Readiness of our military units at the
local level military spouses and family
members play critical roles behind the
scenes in supporting our service members
the result of that commitment affects
their own ability to pursue employment
and establish their own careers which is
highlight Ed by the unemployment rate of
this
demographic military spouses are
unemployed at a rate of 21% a rate that
is significantly higher than their
civilian counterparts but like their
civilian counterparts our military
families rely on two incomes to meet
their basic needs offering employment
preference may be the Difference Maker
when looking at ways to reduce the
stubbornly high unemployment rate House
Bill 64 also has the opportunity to not
only benefit our military families but
also the employers actively looking to
recruit talent for some employers
providing a military spouse preference
will assist with hiring goals enhance
Talent amongst their Workforce and
support the local military Community
military spouse hiring preference would
be a well-deserved recognition of the
sacrifices made by military families as
well as a sound economic investment in
New Hampshire's Workforce when military
spouses are able to secure stable and
fulfilling employment they are more
likely to contribute to their
communities this in turn can lead to
increased economic growth reduced
poverty rates in a more resilient
Workforce on behalf of the defense
department I'd like to thank the
committee for your consideration of this
proposal and I'm especially grateful for
the tremendous efforts New Hampshire has
historically made in supporting our
service members and their families we
also thank the bill sponsor
representative Terry Roy for his
continued advocacy and support of our
defense St State leaon office
initiatives and I'd be happy to uh take
any of your questions at this
time thank you very much Miss wette um
so I let's Circle back to uh
representative Lloyd's question that I
already alluded to about uh other states
doing this type of thing do you have any
knowledge from there are there are a few
a handful um that have implemented this
particular policy priority Maryland uh
was actually the most recent to
implement it and I know a few of my
colleagues are actually doing the same
thing uh as I am testifying in
legislatures across the country uh in
support of of the policy priority but at
at this present time there are four or
five and I can get the list uh of those
states to you Mr chairman after this
meeting are you aware of any hiccups or
issues that Maryland or these other
states have had uh implementing this
type of initiative there haven't been uh
thus far but I can ask my colleagues who
have have worked in those individual
states right now it's not a a policy
priority that's on the dedicated list of
10 from the defense department um it's a
pilot uh at the moment uh and really to
work uh on any way we can to reduce the
unemployment rate for for military
spouses because it it hasn't really
budged from that 21 22% Mark for for
quite some
time okay thank you for that this is
slated to be exact uh in a week so if
you or or Mr fras or anyone else wanted
to U uh if you come across any addendum
type information that you want to get to
the committee um before next Friday
before we exec it uh feel free to uh
share it particularly um if there are
other state experiences that might be
relevant for us to be aware of uh
represent mandal Mom thank you Mr
chairman uh for the record would you
mind clarifying that 48% statistic um I
have 48% of active duty spouses report
and it was something about
employment yep so in 2021 there was a
Department of Defense survey sent to
military families um and it it surveys
their experience in the military uh with
PCS moves access to education employment
and just quality of overall quality of
life and in that survey 48% of
respondents um those active duty
military spouses identifi having a
problem finding uh meaningful employment
when they relocate to their next Duty
station thank you you're
welcome uh representative
Bennett thank you Mr chairman um I just
had a question about the
21% um employment uh I think you said
spouse military spouse unemployment
Minister okay thank you um is that
including people that maybe they don't
want to have employment or is that just
based on people who want employment and
can't find it yeah that that figure is
based solely on Military spouses who
have are seeking employment and can't
find it so that's not including those
who have chosen to um stay home to take
care of family or those who have just
given up their job search or have given
up their professional license because
it's too burdensome and cumbersome to
train transfer their professional
license from one state to the
other representative plant thank you Mr
chair thanks for taking my question um
just wondering this we're talking when
we talk public employment we're talking
about uh State Employment within the
state of New Hampshire also probably
Municipal employment for municipalities
um does this type of preference uh
already exists for federal employment at
the federal level for federal positions
there was was a hiring uh preference
executive order from the previous
president um but it was an executive
order um so with the transfer of power
that uh recently happened uh that
executive order is is no longer in
place that's uh just a moment R some
Hemingway uh very interesting question
and your answer was it was in a federal
exec presidential executive order
correct in this area and so natur we're
hearing a lot about executive orders is
is this an executive order that's still
in effect it it's not it it was an
executive order by uh former President
Biden for federal civilians uh so
federal employment so military spouses
would have preference for federal
civilian
positions but it with the transfer of
power that's it's not a okay and so that
that executive order is not in effect at
this time in the federal level to my
okay thank you for that good good
question representative
Hemingway thank you Mr chairman thank
you for taking my question so a lot of
the stats that I see is is uh relative
to active duty pcsing and everything
like that I I understand the the process
on that having uh been in the my father
was in the Air Force and and I served 10
years on active duty and traveled um so
I understand the the process and and the
uh the partner the spouse be it male or
female that has an issue getting
employment so does this cover the
National Guard I know veteran is a
veteran uh but a lot of this language is
related to active duty so the bill as
written defines a military spouse as uh
an individual that is married to an
active duty service member and holds a
valid deer card um so if you wanted to
include those members those military
spouses of the garden reserve the
definition of military spouse in statute
would also have to be
amended as written it would cover active
duty Guardsmen so those AGR uh members
um but but as written it's it's active
duty military
spouses other questions and just to add
on to that of which there are just under
500 uh living in New Hampshire
active
duty that's a good statistic thank you
for that one anything
else thank you Miss wette you're for
your service and for coming in here
today uh Mr Kevin Grady is still in the
house uh he I know he has a a uh
military spouse because he in this very
committee room he and the spouse I
believe testified on a different measure
in a different committee so uh Mr grd's
asked for 3 minutes welcome back
I'll get it done a lot faster than that
Mr chairman uh for the record again my
name is Kevin Grady 25y year Air Force
veteran and a 20 uh seven-year resident
of the town of hookit New Hampshire the
state veteran advisory committee
supports this legislation it it fits
right in with our our Mantra that when
one of us serves the whole family serves
uh for perspective as the chairman
mentioned um I moved 10 times in a
25-year career including three overseas
tours two to the the Far East and one to
Germany and my wife had to reinvent
herself every single different place
that we went so something like this is I
in our view is a relatively small price
to pay especially for those of us who
know the sacrifices that our military
spouses make close aboard that's really
all I wanted to tell
you thank you Mr Grady
questions seeing none uh thanks again
thank you sir
Danielle Albert is here welcome Danielle
Danielle is representing the New
Hampshire Department of Labor um she's
asked for less than five minutes it does
not say if whether she supports or
opposes the
measure um uh
welcome good morning thank you for
having me I'm Danielle Albert I'm the
Deputy Commissioner of the New Hampshire
Department of Labor um And to clarify
the department is neutral on the bill um
we are here to relay that we have
reviewed the language in particular as
it relates to the amendments to RSA 275g
which fall underneath the labor statutes
um and are here to offer just a few
points of technical consideration uh
based on the review of that language um
I will start um and I'll I'll use the
lines and the numbers so looking at page
two uh line 25 under um section 4 there
is a newly added definition of military
spouse and it's pointing towards the
same meaning is in RSA
2154 when we look at RSA 2154 it's
actually defining um service connected
injuries so we're not certain that
that's the intended definition it
doesn't appear to Define military spouse
so as a technical Point um if if that is
not the intended uh statutory reference
for defining a military spouse we would
highlight that um and the only other
technical point that we would um note is
that on page three line three as it
relates to verification of eligibility
under 275 G3 um we understand the uh
amendment to that provision to uh
specify that a private employer may
require a veteran um to now uh provide
any qualifying document under RSA 2150
there's a large enumerated list under
2150 and we understand um that reference
we would simply note that the language
in that provision um remains that the
employer may ask the veteran and it
doesn't encompass or include the
military spouse or active duty members
that have been added by definition to
the statutory provision um so our
reading of that and our understanding of
that would be that it would remain
limited to Veterans and would not
Encompass the newly defined
individuals and with that I'm happy to
take any
questions thank you for that I was
trying to make some notes while you were
speaking um on these on the technical
points that you raised
I would ask if you could uh have you
submitted anything in writing I have not
but I am happy to do so if that would be
of benefit if you could uh as I
mentioned to representative Roy if you
could get um
your uh recommended technical
considerations to me uh by Monday or
Tuesday at the latest so that if if we
do need to make any language changes
after reviewing uh your written
submission uh we'll have time to to do
that more than happy to absolutely okay
appreciate that
questions all right uh thank you for
being here my pleasure thank you seeing
no more pink cards
for as you were
uh uh you can have uh more than more
time than that the representative if you
would hit the turn that little light on
sure
uh thank you Mr chair again I'm
representative kraton uh from the labor
committee um just contextually and and
the testimony that you heard resonates I
served for 30 years my family moved 23
times in those 30 years and I commanded
several thousands of soldiers who also
moved all the
time
and the challenges both within schools
for the kids kids going into new schools
and for spouses finding employment are
substantial and if we as a legislature
can make it easier for those 500
families in the state of New Hampshire I
think it's something we should do that's
all I've got Mr
chair thank you very
much no
questions seeing no questions thank you
uh Mr
co-sponsor and uh we will at this time
close the hearing public hearing on
hp64 and uh it's exactly 10:40 uh the
fast clock is a little fast so we'll go
by the slow clock it's
10:40 and uh that brings us right on
schedule today uh which we like to be
and stay Federal and Veterans when we
when we can when it works out and uh it
is now 10:40 HB
256 establishing a committee to study
the federal government's response to the
1967 attack on the USS Liberty that was
an attack by uh Israeli military forces
this is a measure that we had in this in
this committee last term uh we sent it
to interim
study and represent Manion chaired that
interim I believe yeah represent Manion
chaired that interim study and the
recommend
recommendation uh from the interim study
committee which we adopted was to uh
revisit this uh bill which is why we're
here looking at HB 256 at this time um
representative saberin um is the prime
prime sponsor um rep Manion again is a
co-sponsor uh so repres of Sabin welcome
and uh we're very much looking forward
to having you introduce this measure and
um so H have
it thank you chairman MF members of the
committee I'm representative saborin D
Schwaner from Rockingham District 30
seab Brook um we have members of the
crew and their families here today to
testify I also have a written testimony
to submit from the family of David Edwin
Lewis one of the crew members of the USS
Liberty was from New Hampshire he lived
in Co Brook passed away in 2021 he spent
his entire life hoping uh to see you
know an investigation of this incident
and upon listening to the crew that is
here today I think you'll understand a
little bit more about what exactly uh
we're discussing um does anyone have any
technical questions on the
bill questions on the
language on the bill as presented as we
have it in front of
us uh represent seeing no questions on
the language at this time
awesome okay representative Barton from
Littleton is he is he
here yes than Bon we uh is represent
Sabin D Shier
mentioned uh and we knew this last term
uh go ahead if if I have your card uh
yes if if you could um go ahead and take
a seat
um representative Baron from from
Littleton we know there was a uh there
was a New Hampshire presence on that
boat um I believe there were more than
one but
most uh prominent was uh one of the
senior officers who just passed away
very recently a couple years ago perhaps
so uh welcome RS of Barton um thank you
what can you add to um to what we're
looking at here yes thank you Mr
chairman um I just want add uh I support
this uh piece of legislation recently I
watched a a video on YouTube with an
interview of a member of uh of that
particular crew who spoke about that
incident um during that interview and he
must be around 80 80 years old there
aren't too many survivors of of this um
he spoke that it was very hush hush um
they weren't allowed to speak about
exactly what happened um he said that
they didn't receive uh aid from our own
ships neighboring by and there seemed to
be some kind of um questionable activity
that has gone um really unanswered for
the people who lost uh
unnecessarily um family members um many
years ago and by the IDF and um they
they never got the answers that they
deserved from the the Fed so I think for
our New Hampshire constituents um we we
owe them uh the decency in respect of of
a response to at least look into this
and and press our um our federal
delegation uh to uh to pursue
this thank you representative just a
comment I described the bill when I
introduced it um what I want to do here
is just clarify that the intent of this
bill is to establish a committee to
study the federal government's response
to the 1960s have an attack on the USS
Liberty so the the issue that the
committee this committee is going to
have to make a decision on is whether we
support a a committee being established
or not and that's something that we we
going to continue to take testimony
we're going to talk about it and we'll
eventually exec this and make a decision
on that uh I was am old enough to
remember this this incident the the
captain of the USS Liberty won the
Congressional Medal of Honor for keeping
his ship afloat under a horrific attack
uh that's something that I remember uh I
think it was 12 years old when that
occurred it was um a very prominent news
item at the time I it was in June of
so my question for you is looking at the
membership of the proposed committee
should one be established uh do you have
any
questions or are you comfortable with
the committee as
proposed I I didn't see proposed
committee members for the subcommittee I
I would like to be uh appointed to that
committee um based on knowledge and 16
years working with the dod um I believe
you're you're correct that there was
significant amounts of heroism in in
Saving that boat because the IDF took
out all of the radios on that boat so
they couldn't radio for help and there
was one radio human who um who rigged a
line and and squeaked out an SOS and and
still that help was delayed but they
stayed afloat long enough that they
eventually got got assistance so there's
definitely a bunch of Heroes on that
boat and they they deserve answers I I
don't think that it was an
accident well I and and I know other
committee members have things that we
want to to say is and that's really more
appropriate for executive session we're
here to listen to you and and perhaps
ask some questions U for the F people
watching at home the
committee proposed committee shall be as
follows four members of the House of
Representatives appointed by the speaker
one member of the Senate appointed by
the president of the Senate uh one
member of the public appointed by the
governor so that would be a uh a
six-person
committee and the members of the
committee their duties would be to study
the federal government's response
specific Ally investigate to the best of
its ability whether the US government
properly determined the culpability of
Israeli civilian and military officials
in that attack so that's the proposal uh
any anything else for um representative
Baron he who is not listed as a
sponsor
um but he is a uh a supporter questions
for representative represent mandle
bomb thank you Mr chairman so I want to
First say that I am empathetic toward
the members of this crew and their
families and thank you for their heroism
what I would love a little bit more
clarity around is what Gap this
committee would fill because it seems to
me like there was a fairly thorough
investigation of this attack um the
Israeli government has apologized for it
and provided compensation to the US
government to um to um to give to the 34
men killed in the attack could you just
clarify a little bit what you're looking
to get out of this committee yes
absolutely so um you're you're correct
in all of your statements um what we
don't have and what we never got was
answers as to actually what happened
this committee could um could interview
with surviving crew members who are
getting much much older and uh we could
get answers from I'll interview all of
them and and do uh do the research to
actually give um
uh a clear concise research well
researched uh answer not something that
the federal government came up with uh
to protect one of our allies um so that
would be I would uh expect the interest
of this committee um to to get the real
answers and actually get that out there
it's the real answers are deserved
follow up follow up
thank you Mr chairman um so there
haven't been any any books or videos or
any other material that use um direct
interviews from
survivors I I believe that there was a
gag order or the equivalent of a gag
order of all the crewmen and now that
they're getting close to uh dying they
don't care anymore and they're willing
to speak regardless of the con
consequences so we may actually be able
to get some real answers now as to what
happened another followup go ahead thank
you Mr chairman so if these service
members are providing their
testimony
um and and breaking this gag order would
that put any would there be any
potential consequences for the State of
New Hampshire and this committee if
we're asking them to do that I not an
expert on on those laws but I suspect
that they would be uh of federal orders
and um not under the purview of the
State of New Hampshire it would be
voluntary testimony at at their own risk
thank
you okay represent Bon I know uh you're
going to be here to be the you're the
prime sponsor of hcr8 which is coming
later okay so I have two cards so you're
not a sponsor of 256 but you're speaking
in support of the bill correct okay got
it anything else for yes represent
f um I just had kind of a clarification
on representative mandal bomb's question
so when I was reading up on uh the
incident I saw that there are many books
and I think at least one documentary so
none of those interviewed
survivors uh I haven't read every every
book but what I am aware of is that um
there was a uh an an order for these
crew members not to speak since right
after the attack um and uh most of the
crewmen kept that order there have been
some interviews where where crew members
are speaking out for the reasons that I
said but um I think that it's an
opportunity to get all surviving members
of of that ship to um to testify before
a subcommittee and uh you know give us a
very clear concise um
uh you know story of what actually
happened that we could put out as a
state and that we could press um press
the FED on and say hey what you that
happen didn't
happen represent floss yeah um a
followup so what's the
expectation that uh this testimony from
survivors would
uh what's the end goal I suppose uh what
do you want the federal government to do
after this
committee I I would expect that when we
find the answer aners that we didn't get
from the FED that we deserved many years
ago um that uh that they would release
information similar to uh some of the uh
the information that was released on on
the assassinations of RFK and Martin
Luther King and JFK I think probably
some of the the case stuff would be
unsealed and um I think there would be
they would be more apt to do that um in
in uh in DC if we came and said hey we
have the goods right here we know most
of the story that we didn't get from
actual I Witnesses tell us the rest of
the
story I think it would be a good good
means to to uh pressure I think that's
the intent of the Prime sponsors um
putting this
forward represent mle bomb thank you Mr
chairman so so to
clarify the intent is to better
understand the US government's role
in this
situation um I guess
I just back up for a moment there has
been a lot of criticism of Israel lately
just given um the ongoing conflicts in
the Middle East and I'm a bit
hesitant um that this bill
might might be be biased against our
Ally or might be looking
to seek further justice from them from
them is this really just focused on the
US government's
role uh I would expect it's not um I you
know I'm again I'm not the prime sponsor
of this legislation I speak in in
support of it um I I support Israel but
in
1967 something happened and uh and you
know it it doesn't doesn't seem right
and we ought to have the the real clear
answers as to why there were specific
attacks on our ship um uh I i' hope that
the committee members are unbiased in
their in their research and their
information gathering um and that you
know we get an unbiased Report with with
clear facts other
questions Reon Manion thank you Mr chair
thanks for taking my question just to
piggyback on that like had this occurred
and it was like Great Britain or turkey
or something fired on us you'd still be
in support of doing a full investigation
doesn't matter which country did it
absolutely thank
you good question anything
else see no hands thank you
representative uh I'm sorry uh
representative Bennett sorry thank you
sorry um I was just curious how many
people from New Hampshire were on that
ship I I don't recall the exact number
um I'm I'm sure he can find the uh the
the crew
online um or it'll come up in the in the
committee's research for sure but I know
that there were members of of New
Hampshire that that were that crewed
that
boat as per earlier comment the uh a
gentleman from a naval Commander from
Littleton was I think he was a
intelligence officer or something like
that somebody's saying no we'll get a
good answer later I I know someone back
there has an answer to that uh question
about the New Hampshire presence on the
boat anything
else saying No Hands thank you
representative thank you representative
wheeler is in the house he's asked for
two
minutes welcome back representative
wheeler representative from Peterboro I
believe yes sir thank you chairman
Moffett friends and colleagues on the
house state and federal Relations
Committee for the record my name is
representative Jonah wheeler I represent
the towns of Peterboro and Sharon to
answer your question there was a
commander on the ship named Commander
Lewis from colbrook uh
and I'm here today Mr chairman to lend
my support for this very important
legislation
the
men the service people who are on that
boat have not been heard by the United
States government for 58 years there was
a false investigation that happened
false investigation paty investigation
that the the federal government held to
lie about what happened on that boat the
official story the American people were
given that that was that that boat was
attacked for 5 minutes by one torpedo
and that an immediate apology was given
that could not be further from the truth
and I you know there's people here who
were on that boat who are going to
testify to that so I won't speak to that
too much but to me Mr chairman the state
of New Hampshire has the opportunity
here to
be to stand strong and our
transparent open government that we take
pride in and open up the books and
transparency and start the first genuine
investigation into this issue that has
occurred these again I'll let these men
speak to it themselves but what they
went through on that boat is horrifying
as I was sitting back there listening to
other people testify I had to listen to
them remember it and remembering it
right now as they sit here as they have
to come constantly to state after State
testifying retelling their story just to
get heard by their government these
people
served in one of the most dangerous
times that this world has faced maybe
other than now and here they are saying
the government lied about what we went
through and we're going to say well we
won't even study it we we have a study
committee here before us this isn't
legislation with a stick this isn't
doing anything other than saying that
we're going to study the issue and how
however you might feel about the issue I
think you should look into it if you
feel differently than angry that the
government has lied about it you should
want a study committee because no
answers have been given about this so
I'm 21 years old I was far from alive in
the
1967 but I'm here today because I'm a
student of history and I'm tired of the
United States government lying to its
people and as a member of the state
government of n Hampshire who has sworn
an oath to the United States
Constitution I feel it's my duty to
speak up in favor of these men who
served our nation and have been lied to
by their leaders so I don't really have
anything other than that to say and I
think you take any questions I will take
questiones but other people will speak
more eloquently to this that I can all
right thank you Mr chairman so again I'm
not I'm not doubting the veracity of of
the claims by the survivors who are here
in this room today I thank you for your
service and appreciate you stepping
forward on this matter I'm just trying
to get a sense of the whole situation
here um and representative wheeler you
said twice that there was a false
investigation that the federal
government helds apart from the
testimony of these survivors what
evidence do you have that it was a false
investigation uh it's my opinion and
they lied about the investigation
there's plenty of evidence that if you
go back and listen and watch the
testimony about the investigation you
read up on it that investigation was
just as bad as the warrant commission
was other questions representative
gagy thank you Mr chairman thank you
representative for taking my
question if you allow me I'd like to
read a short exerpt and ask the witness
for his opinion on what I have here we
do need a question so if this leads to a
question uh it would go ahead it would
lead to this
hopefully okay uh there was a commission
set up by the government by by Jag but
Judge Advocate General in June of
1967 uh I was assigned as there's a
captain here I was assigned as senior
legal counsel for the Navy's Court of
inquiry to the brutal attack on USS
Liberty which had occurred in June 8th
the late Admiral Isaac kid president of
the court and I were given only one week
to gather evidence for the Navy's
official investigation into the attack
despite the fact that we both had
estimated that a proper Court of inquiry
into an attack of this magnitude would
take at least 6 months to
conduct now I'm going to skip a whole
bunch of
stuff it was our shared belief based on
the documentary evidence and testimony
we
were that we received
firstand that the Israeli attack was
planned and deliberate and could not
possibly have been an
accident I continue I'm skipping a whole
bunch of stuff so so I can get your your
comments Admiral kid and I both felt it
necessary to travel to Israel to
interview the Israelis who took part in
the attack Admiral kid telephoned
Admiral McCain to discuss making
arrangements Admiral McCain
was the
higher used the boss Admiral kid later
told me that Admiral McCain was adamant
that we were not to travel to Israel or
contact the Israelis concerning this
matter
and I'm going to end here I think I know
from personal conversations I had with
Admiral kid at president Lyndon Johnson
and Secretary of Defense Robert magn
magn magn excuse me magnam the dod
ordered him to conclude that the attack
was a case of mistaken identity despite
overwhelming evidence to the contrary
Admiral kid told me after returning from
Washington DC that he had been ordered
to sit down with two civili from either
the White House or the defense
department and rewrite portions of the
Court
hearings sorry about that
okay yeah the other way I got one must
be almost done I'm sorry I apologize for
the delay here but this I feel is
important because I was a sa and there
is a question coming there is absolutely
a question
coming Admiral kid also told me that he
had been ordered to put the lid on
everything having to do with the attack
on USS Liberty we were never to speak of
it and we were to caution everyone else
involved that they could never speak of
it
again what say you on this matter I say
that you know best as a sailor yourself
a member of the Navy that that is what
happened and there is a number of
information out there a lot of
information about Lyndon Johnson
attitude towards this attack and how he
did not care about those soldiers who
were being bombarded doesn't matter who
the country that was bombarding them you
have your you're the commanderin-chief
you have soldiers being bombarded your
ship is being sunk it does not matter
who is shooting at you you take action
and he instead of taking action took
action to help rewrite Court hearings he
took action the commission took action
to rushed them as was stated the Admiral
said that he had one week to gather what
he said he needed 6 months to gather
that's what I mean when I say false
investigation you have people in power
who have a vested interest in not
telling the truth who are out there
trying to say oh we we'll study the
issue and then producing a report such
as this we have before us an opportunity
to genuinely study this issue to compile
that information in a official state
government commissioned committee that
we have charged with the power that we
have as legislators and I think
representative PL or gagy you're
absolutely correct that that's that's
one of the many pieces of information
that should be brought forward in a
study committee like
this other questions seeing none thank
you representative wheeler a student of
History we can't have too many students
of history in my opinion no we can as a
history need more we need more okay uh
we do have a finite amount of time as
always uh but we have at least I think
at least a couple survivors from that
ship and who have traveled some distance
and have taken some time so I definitely
want to make sure that we give them some
time uh we don't have unlimited time but
uh we want very much to hear from them
uh we heard from uh we did had a this
measure a year year ago or last term and
spent uh a great deal of time on it so
we're already uh Fair those of us who've
been on the committee already fairly
familiar with with the uh the incident
the question is whether or not we want
to do a committee but I'd like to uh is
Tom muan here Tom uh you were here last
term I believe
right uh you were here La you were here
last term when we took this up I believe
correct welcome back and uh thank you
your service and um please share with us
what you um what you uh can
share Tom traveled here from Auburn
Maine thank
you my name is Tom Molen I was on Supply
Department I was a ships Barber and I
ran the ship store at the same
time um I'm going to give you
um what happened to me when I was there
I my my duty on the ship when during an
attack or any time of uh of being
threatened was to go to DC Central which
is damage control
Central and in damage control Central we
would answer the calls phone calls uh
from different departments mine was from
the the bridge anything the captain
wanted he would he would give it to his
messenger the messenger had the direct
line to me and we would talk and and we
would
dispatch whatever he
wanted we had also uh there was three of
us in this little one little 8 by8
room and I'll start off by going during
that
afternoon on a nice clear day
uh we were being observed by by the
Israel planes One Flew so close to us on
the side of the ship that I could see
that that the pilot was smiling at us
and waving and we waved back at him and
he took off and he waved his W
wings
um then I uh lunch was over or our break
was over and I went up to my my to open
up the barber shop and two guys were
already waiting for me we got in there
and the first guy I call him posty he
was he was the post office man
manager he got in the chair and Smitty
uh he sat down and we just started
talking and and the first gr
kind excuse me
the bullets when they hit the
ship they came down and you could feel
the whole ship okay I'm okay M you could
feel the whole ship
rattling and we didn't know what it was
and after after the
rattles I heard
screams I didn't know what the hell is
going on then all of a sudden it's a
general alarm about the horn starts
ringing man your Battle Stations man
your Battle
Stations so we all start taking off and
all three of us head out start heading
towards the hatch goes out from my my
little shop was just had a hallway
across it and there was a hatch and
there was a
Stairway Smitty went out the door first
and he went
Left Post he went out second and he went
right and I could take the stair away
but before the stairway I looked out the
door I saw the plane banking straighten
out and I started
firing you could see the Sparks from the
from the wings and he was firing at at
Smitty I knew it I knew he was going to
get
him then I looked at that plane again
and I thought I thought the pilot saw me
so I turned and ran for the stairs and I
dove and as I'm do my room is like
lighting
up and luckily my body was underneath
the
stairway uh down below me uh there was a
men waiting to come upstairs but they
didn't say a word they just
what I'm sorry this is my first
time that I I'm able to say this
I made it down to the stairs and ran ran
through the the
galley and through the galley I I got
into my get into the hallway and into my
area my damage controls area damage
control room was 8 by8 it's a small
room thank you
sir it's a it's a small room
and I got I got in I think I it might
have been first and then
and Steve gersack was the second and
then then Lieutenant we all showed
up we started talking we grabbed our
phones and we started talking and each
time the planes were coming they were
making a figure over the top of our of
our ship and when they when those
bullets would come you think you're in a
in a
barrel and it was loud very loud I'm
still ringing in my ears from
it and and
uh this went on sle times that the
planes would go one way and then the
other way and this rattle come down the
St the ship would vibrate and you could
feel it and you could feel it
tilt and the screams after just about
every damn one of them
we got
going
and I'll look at my notes for a minute
here kind of cool me
down they did about eight
swipes a piece those
ples and then those eight wipes they
wiped out all of the all of the antennas
all all the Gunners there's four on his
post he was cut in half he got hit by a
40 caliber uh 40 mm
Cannon nobody lives through that Smitty
was hit with a through the butt with a
50 caliber machine gun on it on a route
to go going now Smitty was
later but posting of them made at that
time
uh I felt tremendous pressure from those
bullets and and it made and it became
silent when when we when the planes were
empty and about and I talking to virgal
he was telling me of what was taking
place and we dispatched to those
areas and then he said there's two big
planes coming two big planes
coming and all of a sudden they're
dropping Napal Napal was very hot fire
bombs one of them hit right over that
deck right there we were one floor below
below the deck right against the the
bridge so we were exposed and one of the
bombs landed either directly on us or
right at right next to us that the room
got so down hot that we thought we would
have we' have to get out but we had
dispatched a fire crew and a fire crew
knocked it down quick enough to keep us
inside after after the na palom bombs
went by and they they did a lot of lot
more damage I wish I could bring
pictures of the ship but I did not I'm
sorry after after that that bombing
Mi Mr Mullen I I first of all I want to
thank you
for having the U the courage to relive
uh with is clearly uh a horrific painful
experience and U of course thank you for
your service as
always I I think we're all extremely
captivated by by living through this
with you we have a finite amount of time
and I I want
to and I want to give one or two other
folks a chance to also have have some
time um I'll make it shorter um and I
and would you take maybe one
question if yeah go pleas please uh
please finish but and maybe take a
question but I I also want to uh give a
couple other folks a chance to to weigh
so so please please continue
okay all right the PT boats SC and it's
time for them they sent three Torpedoes
at us and we avoided him the captain
would could steer that ship pretty well
he know how to handle it really good and
then the other guys they sent two more
Torpedoes at us the last one is going
right straight at us and they said man
prepare for prepare for impact when it
hit we all got thrown all over the
place um everything everything was dark
we were screaming at each other cuz our
ears were swice we were only 70t from
the
blast we they asked repel
borders I mean not repel borders they
asked to prepare to Abandoned Ship so
the guys haded get in the Life rafts
over when the life rafts went over went
over Israel shot up the life rafts then
they picked one of the life rafts up in
the boat I'm told
and they Rec they thought they
recognized the USS Liberty that's what
they they told us that I was told
anyway that bomb was that hole is 20 by
40 it's a large hole it went right
up uh the ship was leaning at the time
and we were about 4T off the water those
three part three PT boats I'll call them
PT boats
then start took the machine guns after
they they cut took care of the rafts run
around the boat firing the machine guns
with Armond piing bullets and put holes
50 caliber holes all the way around the
boat all they want to sink us they don't
want us
alive they left whena empty and then
whena empty a few minutes later three
helicopters are coming after us three
helicopters were armed with with
commanders in there and they're ready
ready to take the rest of us out during
the blast I I we were unaware of it but
Virgil told me he says you guys are
trapped in that room you can't get
out so when they we had the sign of
repel borders when they said repel
borders that means we go grab our guns
and we can fight by handguns off off off
the uh the ship well they they didn't
plan on the armor being cut in half and
losing the only man with the key to get
to the
weapons we were we were going to we were
all going knew we were dead
then the
uh
uh then the pilot one out of the pilot
one of the helicopters came to the
bridge and Virgil is telling me
everything is going on he said the the
Comm the helicopter came real close and
they took a mic and they said can we
help
you so that meant that word got
out and we and somebody knew that Israel
was attacking a
ship the captain gave him the
finger and they turned around and took
off again that's my story of that can I
tell you one more thing sure two days
later Admiral kid came on the
boat and he he had he in front got in
front of us we all got around him he
takes his bars off his collar and he
said he commended us for being such
strong
men only there's only about 70 of us
guys left everybody else is gone in the
helicopters and gone
right we had loaded 17 were wounded and
34 men were dead were all off the
ship he took he took those those offers
and he commanded commanded us he thought
we we did a wonderful job and then he
asked for a few comments he got him then
he puts his bars back on and he said no
I'm going to tell you
guys if you ever say one word to your
friend or your family or anybody each
other I'll put you in jail and you ain't
ever going to come out and he repeated
that a couple times and took
off and this is from Admiral kid that's
from animal kid now I have been angry at
that son of a ever
since he destroyed my faith in this
government well I think uh I think that
we get that and again I've already
thanked you once I'll thank you again
for your very compelling in in Brave
testimony here uh the one question that
I did want to ask you and you can
probably answer yes or no um do you
think the federal
government was engaged in a major
coverup that still needs attention
there's no doubt there's no question in
my mind I'll take that as a yes that's a
yes uh anyone else have any questions uh
represent
Foss thank you so much for for coming
here and for your bravery um in your
like perfect world I suppose what do you
want the federal government to do if
this committee does find that the
investigation was uh I suppose at the
the very least inadequate what what is
it that um that just personally you know
because I know you can't speak for all
survivors what is your ideal outcome My
outcome is to have them apologize to
each and each and every one of
us just it's all you know and not make a
mistake like that again for somebody
else other questions repr mandle bom
thank you Mr chairman so I'm going to
Echo my fellow members of the committee
and thanking you for your powerful
testimony and and your bravery on that
day what would it mean to you if we were
if the state were to form such a
committee I'm sorry you have to speak up
yeah in your own words what would it
mean to you if the state were to form
this committee what would it mean to
me it would make me feel like the door
is opening but finally get some answers
thank you other questions representative
plant sir thank you for my question
thank you for your testimony appreciate
your service sincerely in your opinion
since you were there and had a firsthand
account do you agree that the outcome of
the invest ation that the federal
government did in your personal
experience there do you believe they
were Israeli aircraft or are you saying
that it may have been a different state
actor the F the first two planes that
went by were were not
marked but the but the boats were marked
they had flags on them saying that they
were from Israel they were flly they
were they had their Israel flags on them
thank
you seeing no other hands uh represent
Rollins thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my question um as a gold sta
father I understand the pain and what
you guys have gone through okay I've
lost my son in
Iraq I had
closure I'm asking you have you people
had closure yet on this issue how can
you thank you thank
you thank you Mr Mullen thank you very
much I have three more cards
uh kathern Peterson has asked for four
minutes Jason Gard has asked for three
minutes we we we do have we a schedule
that we're obviously going to be
somewhat flexible with I do uh want to
give uh Michael lay some time is is he
here right there uh I don't want to have
any time limit on him um because he's
come from um Florida and uh I I think uh
Mr L is a Survivor I'm pretty
of the liberty so uh please tell us what
you'd like like us to hear uh first of
all I want to thank Tom this is the
first time he's ever talked openly about
what he saw okay I'm I uh didn't go
through the horrors that Tom went
through I was hit on the first
strafing I do want to say that it was an
incredibly beautiful day the ocean was
like a
mirror and my biggest problem now is
nobody's ever asked me officially what I
saw or what happened that
day
and they accepted I made a mistake I
didn't know it was a US
ship okay the day was beautiful I saw
one of the fighters it was an unmarked
Mirage French Mirage jet I'm told he was
flying the same way we were and he
wasn't even 60 feet above us
I could have waved to the pilot that day
and he could have waved back that's how
close he was and I turned I was going
going up to the 04 level that's the
highest deck you could be on the ship
outside and it was just the full width
of the ship but maybe 15 ft in
size and I turned to the officer up
there that's supposed to identify all
the planes that go by and I said did you
see that fighter sir and he said no
where is it and I walked closer to him
and turned to point to the fighter that
I saw and that's when the first
strafing uh it came by and like Tom
explained the ship shook like crazy and
I looked down and there was blood coming
out of every part of my body and I
looked at the lieutenant and he looked
just like me and I said hey I'm getting
the F out of here and I ran hit the
ladder just like you see in the movies I
slid down didn't touch a rung got inside
the 03 level inside the ship and there
was glass everywhere and I didn't
realize it but my leg had knee had been
shattered and I fell to the deck and
crawled down another deck inside the
ship
uh at that point uh one of my uh
Shipmates and this is comical how crazy
the mine works I was crawling around the
corner going into office's country and
he goes are you hurt and I honestly
looked up to this shipmate of mine and
says no I like crawling on the deck and
we both laughed I mean I can't get over
that I even could do that but we did
laugh but anyhow you threw a tourin on
my leg and went and to get help to bring
me down to Sick Bay and I don't know how
long it took him to get there uh but I
know I did black out a lot a number of
times before he got back and they threw
a tourniquet on my leg they put me in a
stret and started carrying me down into
Sick Bay uh as we're turning the corner
the Corman came by and told him take the
tourniquet off his leg we don't want him
to lose it and uh with that they put me
on the deck and he starts on tying it
and a rocket comes through the overhead
now I'm two decks inside the ship and I
can see blue sky and the only time you
ever saw a cloud was a little white
cloud on that hole where the rocket had
come
through then I blanked out and I woke up
in sick Bay uh which was the mes decks
they converted all the tables into beds
and put mats uh mattresses on and I can
remember uh passing out waking up and
one time I woke up prepared for torpedo
attack I remember hearing that I don't
remember the torpedo
hitting I do remember hearing prepare to
Abandoned
Ship uh and I don't know if I blacked
out anymore or not but I do remember
them canceling the abandoned ship and
later on I had heard what Tom Tom had
told you uh they were sinking the life
rafts as they threw them over the side
so I'm assuming the captain thought we
were safer to stay on the ship as long
as it didn't sink then to try to go over
the
side uh again it was a beautiful day
there's no way that ship that plane did
not know we were an American ship on the
bow we had a letter g 10 ft
tall tr5 general research technical
vessel is what we were on it was a spy
ship it was controlled I'm told by the
NSA and unfortunately with a torpedo hit
was the only
place that the the torpedo could hit us
without sinking us within six inches
either way or the other the split ship
would have split in half and we would
have all died no questions in my mind
um you brought up a number of things
that I wanted to make comments on uh I
did not have Admiral
kid tell me what he told my Shipmates
but every one of my Shipmates have said
the same thing I have never ever once
been officially asked by any government
what I saw that
day and to me if you're doing an
investigation every crew member has to
be
questioned now Admiral kid took a bunch
of them all together and asked them a
question and they answered and then they
were sworn not to talk about it for the
rest of their lives uh from what I
understand the Admiral that did the
commissioned people on board the ship
swore them the secrecy till the day he
died and he died 15 years later and
that's when the assault of the Liberty
came out and that's when they started
talking about it and I think we just
figured we could too so we started
talking myself I went from the Liberty
to the USS America an aircraft
carrier uh that's where they saved my
life I was on there for about two months
they shipped me to Naples Italy they put
us on the top floor so they could
control anybody that could come up and
ask us
questions I was on in uh Naples when
they tried to take out some of the
shrapnel of me I had four cardiac
arrests while they were doing that so
the doctor said we'll leave them in and
if you ever have problems we'll take
them out when you have problems I still
have 52 pieces of shrapnel in
me I went from Naples Italy to the Army
hospital in
Germany when I got to the Germany
hospital they put me in a a ward where
there had to be 15 Vietnam veterans from
the Vietnam War injured I wasn't there
three minutes they picked me up put me
on a gurnie brought me to a private room
and some officer came in and says your
name is
Smith and if anyone ask you about the
Liberty you know nothing now me being a
dumb 23y old kid I figured while I was
in the hospital that's the only time I
had to be quiet I didn't get the threat
that Tom and the crew that didn't get
injured happened the crew was only
294 men that's all we had 174 were
wounded 34 were
dead these few guys saved my life
I'm
sorry it never
stops my problem is the United States
believed Israel that it was a
mistake the ship they claim that was the
the ship that was shelling the beach and
you can't shell the beach with 54 54
5050 caliber guns was half the size
wasn't even
seaworthy it was a animal a cow ship
that they they sh shipped cows or cattle
or something
on the Liberty was an Immaculate ship it
was no way you could make a mistake that
it was anything other than a US
vessel the captain was the biggest pain
in the butt that anyone could be because
he followed the
book going from Norfork to Africa which
was our new normal Duty station if I
went out without a hat on I'd have been
put on report if I didn't salute an
officer I'd have been put on report this
is how ridiculous the captain was we had
General quarter drills which is to
practice for attacks two three times a
week I can remember thinking to myself
this guy's crazy he's too much of this
baloney thank God he did
it the only reason why life today is cuz
he trained everybody to do to do the
right thing I was the electrical
department I was in charge of the
electricity for the ship my duty station
was the generator one of the most
important parts you can have when you're
in a battle you have to have electricity
to keep the ship
running I was hit under for a
strafing okay but my uh my crew knew how
to to act and keep that ship going
because he was we were trained so well
by our captain
you mentioned that the captain got the
Medal of Honor yes but they insulted us
he got it from the secretary of the Navy
in the Naval Shipyard and any other time
anyone got the Medal of Honor they got
it at the White House from the president
of the United
States and he deserved the Medal of
Honor the the doctor was seriously
injured and kept us all alive he
deserved probably the Medal of Honor too
for not letting anybody that got into
that room except one person die die
everyone else survived and the
lieutenant commander that died stayed
away too long by the time he got there
nobody could save
them Mr soulmate thank you so much I
want to make sure you understand that
more people listening and will listen to
your testimony than are in this room
that this is being recorded and is being
watched by many folks and many more will
will be watching it it'll be on YouTube
uh forever mhm so please know that you
were being heard um would you take a
question or two I'll take any question
you want to ask the same question I want
to repeat the same question I asked your
predecessor I think I know the answer do
do you think that the federal government
um covered up uh a serious situation
here yes no doubt in my mind I I figured
that would be your answer that's kind of
why we're here um representative
Foss U thank you sir and thank you as
well for coming to speak here to get
today and um side note I I am really
pleased to see how you and your fellow
survivors are supporting each other
still um I'm also going to ask the same
question what do you want from the
federal government what's your ideal
outcome for me not to feel like they
think I'm a liar
I want the truth what I saw what I told
you that day if you want me to take a a
oath to tell you that I'm telling you
the truth I'm not afraid to do any of
that uh the truth that we they
intentionally attacked us knowing we
were a US
vessel the our commanderin-chief
President Johnson two times called
planes that were coming to our
Aid wouldn't allow them come to our Aid
when we were on our way into the
Mediterranean now normally our our duty
station was the west coast of Africa
we'd spent three months going up and
down the west coast of Africa in the Spy
section of the ship I'm assuming listen
to what was going on the beach and we
were in Aban at the time of the Six Day
War started and then we were ordered to
go into the Mediterranean now I've been
told that the captain asked for a
Destroyer
Escort because we only had 450 caliber
guns we should have never been in that
war zone without an
escort the Admiral told the captain that
he can have air strike help within 12
minutes anywhere in the Mediterranean so
the captain accepted that as okay we'll
be okay now like Tom
mentioned first of all they jammed all
our frequencies to call out emergency we
even though the equipment was working we
couldn't get anything else Mayday but we
did somehow get one Mayday out because
the USS America and the USS Saratoga
sent planes to our
Aid and with that and again I'm only
only tell you what uh Commander Lewis
told me he was really hurt bad uh when
he when the attack happened and he went
on uh a fret or a destroyer I don't know
what ship it wasn't the America and he
met with the Admiral so I'm assuming it
was the flagship and the Admiral told
him that he called the U the the us and
told him that he was sending planes to
help the liberty and I was he told us
that magnam called the planes back
magnam being the Secretary of Defense uh
God bless you and and God bless the
folks who uh the medical people who did
what they did uh back in
1967 uh I think we need to remember them
as well uh I know you came a long way
and as I said uh a lot of people Beyond
this room are hearing and will hear your
words I want to get to the last two uh
two uh folks uh representative G you
have a question only I can defer if the
other two are also
Serv the the last two speakers that I
have cards for uh are not were not on
the ship so go ahead representative
gagy thank you Mr chairman and thank you
sir for taking my question
I'm a Navy guy too Navy guy and I was
there in that area about a year before
you guys got hit oh wow okay now my
understanding is if if I hear your
testimony right that your duty station
was off the west coast of Africa now
normal dut I was involved in that on on
I was a ten Can Sailor the Noah that
picked up John Glenn okay in'
and when we went on these recovery
missions that's where we were stationed
up and down the West Coast of Florida
okay now I see that your Crow and were
you a second class electrician yes okay
uh I'm sorry if I'm going off the deep
end but this is this is so important to
me I Am pro Israel okay your incident
and what's happening now are two
different um pies right what happened to
you guys for my reading here and and
listening to the I think an hour and a
half uh thing for Candace Owens I think
was your name that and and you know and
what scares me a little bit is I
understand everything that you're
talking about going down the ladders all
that stuff
now when now let's go back to uh off the
coast you were do you know for a fact
that you were in international waters
only because they told me where we were
I had no I couldn't tell you how far
okay and
when the Israeli
Jets came on and and started their
action were you you said you were on the
04 deck yes that's top side right
correct is that around the signal signal
bridge over the pilot house it's above
it it's yeah above the pilot house is
that correct two decks above the pil
that was a signal man okay did you
notice that day if we had the American
flag flying uh I can't tell you that I
looked up and saw it okay before then
when you were on way seen many times my
belief on that could you tell me could
you tell me approximately how big that
flag is was I would assume about the
size of that flag there pretty much a
standard one it was the regular flag not
not the holiday one yet probably a 5 by
seven yeah I think I was a sign I was in
charge of the bunting Locker okay okay
so followup uh thank you sir thank you
for your
I really don't have much of anything
else except that I I think I would go
after the then Administration more what
gave the Israelis the The Authority or
the freedom to do what they did know I I
my and my personal opinion sir if you
agree with me or not is that they had
like a cart
blanch to try to get us involved this is
really probably executive session
material I apologize to you chairman I
have no more questions and uh and we
need to let you go Fair Winds following
Seas thank you for coming here uh we're
we're not done with this and um as I
said before God bless you and I want to
get to the last two cards can I say one
more thing of course okay on the second
planes coming to our Aid now I can tell
you what I thought the plane I saw was
UNM moed it attacked us I thought it was
Egypt and I believe the crew the rest of
the crew felt the same way I
did but again Commander Lewis talking to
the Admiral the Admiral had told him
that Johnson turned back the second
flight and said to him we will not
embarrass our allies so we're in the
battle that the battle lasted two hours
about he knows Israel is attacking us we
don't we think it's Egypt we thought it
was Egypt until did the planes have uh
the sty David the the Napal uh PLS had
Napal no did they have the SC Star of
David I I don't think any of the but the
the uh torpedo bat or the uh torpedo
bolts that came uh they had the Star of
David and my Shipmates told me they were
excited we have help coming until they
shot the Torpedoes at us and then for an
hour they Circle the ship now on the
stern of the ship we had gtr5 on the B
port and starbard side in between them
we had Liberty in
English the name of the ship but for an
hour they kept going around shooting at
water level trying to put holes in the
side of the ship to sink
it understood okay
understood and again should should a
committee be established uh that is the
type of thing that the committee would
get into in deta
and we if we had more time I know we'd
all uh love to hear more I do want to
get to uh
Catherine Katherine Peterson who's asked
for four minutes Katherine's here from
nashor uh welcome
Katherine
I good morning everybody in the interest
of time I'm New Hampshire native my
cousin uh was 18 from nare and joined
the Navy and went right off to pick up
these fine gentlemen when Aid was
finally allowed um Jim
makis uh his whole life was affected
same thing wasn't allowed to tell
anybody about the incident whatsoever
and I would like my state I would like
you to find compassion in your hearts to
let these 300 veterans finally speak the
truth and come out from under their gag
order it's not
fair thank thank you uh yeah Miss
Katherine or Miss uh's Peterson yes uh
my dad was also Navy many years the uh
my dad was in the Navy the um the gag
order uh obviously has been lifted
because these folks have uh sounded off
to us and it's uh on uh the worldwide
web it's on YouTube uh they're still
courageous this uh is testimony that uh
supplements what we heard last term um
and thank you for stepping up and saying
what you've said would you take a
question or is anything absolutely
anything else that any other point that
you want us to make sure we is
heard thank you everybody thank you okay
we'll let Jason geard come up and the
last card is uh Jason geard of
Northfield he was a state representative
who initially brought this measure to
this committee last term he's asked for
three minutes uh welcome back uh former
representative thank you chairman member
of the hot mic members of the committee
I'd like to just kind of cover some
things that I think
were not clearly established
previously the fact of the matter is
there are still documents being held by
the federal government that are
classified relating to this event I'm
referencing an antiwar.com article by
Michelle K kukin she's awesome and she's
been fighting in court to get these
documents released unclassified for
years and I just want to read a couple
paragraphs from this to kind of explain
what's going on in court the government
responded this is a very recent I
believe it was last month or so they
ruled on this had we're usually careful
about reading other testimony but if
this I'm sure this is relevant uh so go
ahead and read that but you asked for
three minutes well it's quoting the
Court's response to the reason why they
wouldn't declassify these documents okay
have at it thank you in court the
government responded in part by
asserting that the release of many of
these nearly 60-year-old Records Was
properly denied because the information
they contained if disclosed quote could
be expected to result in damage to the
National Security which includes defense
against transnational terrorism
to to people like me who I'm just a
carpenter I did a little stint in the
state house but wasn't I left uh after
one term I find this to be completely
comical the idea that we have an
incident from the late 60s that can't be
released because it would cause
transnational terrorism I'm not too
concerned about these men being
terrorists I mean what what are we
worried about here it there's there's
been a cover up of such a massive degree
that I think it's hard for us in this
room to really kind of take it in unless
you've been researching this which to a
very detailed degree which I do not
claim to have done but these men lived
it and others have that we've we've
gotten to the point now one of the only
recourse that we have is through the
state government our federal government
has has set sail in a lot of ways and
they don't seem to be coming back to
reality there's a lot of entrenched
interests that want to see certain
things covered up never to see the light
of day again and I I'd want to just
close with establishing why this is the
proper venue for establishing the truth
of a a historical incident but one that
affects us to this day this is from the
same article but I just very quickly
finally New Hampshire and Mo and other
states can and should act as part of a
vigorous federalism as James Madison
observed in Federalist number 45 under
the US Constitution the states quote
retain a very extensive portion of
active sovereignty and state governments
May regarded as constituent and
essential parts of the federal
government as Madison elaborated in
federal list number 51 the United States
is not a single Republic but a compound
Republic with power surrendered by the
people divided between two distinct
governments the division of power
between the federal and state
governments creates a double security to
the rights of the people such that the
different governments will control each
other and it goes a little more detail
but the basic point is that the reason
we have committees in the state
government is to research and do
oversight on situations that need such
research in the F in the federal
government the Committees have much it's
much easier to issue penos and get
testimony and the state government's
been we've been pretty much neutered to
the point that you can't really do much
but this is something that can be done
and this is why realistically this is
why you guys are here yes it's to pass
bills and everything else but more
importantly you don't pass a bill unless
you know what the problem is and you
need to know what the problem is by
investigating that problem hopefully it
makes a little bit of sense but the
point is we need you guys to ask
questions and if you have any questions
we have these folders that were set up
by representative saor that contain all
of information that is really needed to
kind of get a grasp on what's going on
including the obituary of Commander
Lewis who was from colbrook New
Hampshire and he was in charge of all of
the
intelligence uh the NSA guys on board
170 so the majority of the crew were
basically spies or working with them and
then we have emails detailing from the
government saying that that was the only
investigation the naval Court of inquiry
so I I would appre I would it's worth
your time to at least skim through these
documents understand what's going on
this just lot of hisor context that
unfortunately in we had over an hour but
just it can't really be delved into in
enough death so hopefully that kind of
helps and thank you for that uh Mr
gearhard so the could perhaps per Manion
who is a co-sponsor can could uh the
folder of the documents go to him or oh
we have Matt made one for every one of
you guys oh okay uh well there we go
yeah uh any any questions for the
original sponsor represent Lloyd
um thank you uh thank you Mr chairman
and thank you for taking my question so
in your opinion
um
what I don't I'm trying to figure out
how to phrase this in a question so
please forgive me and give me a little
time to pull it together would you
believe um so
what how is how would it be possible for
us
to declassify or or what what do you
think is going to happen when we come up
with information like should this
committee be formed we come up with
information we submit that to the
federal government and then they say
yeah but those records are
classified how do we proceed at that
point because my concern I guess would
be giving any false hope as a
resolution my initial reaction would be
to stop giving them any money and just
stop paying the tax on federal income
but realistically re Trump recently
signed executive B releasing the files
on
MLK the JFK assassination and I believe
RFK
so I'm not I think we're at a different
point now that things that were
previously classified it it's it's much
easier now to make a push for
declassifying these documents from the
same era as these other documents that
are being de Declassified does that make
sort of
sense okay right to know transparency I
think is the point that's being made
here uh one quickie thank you thank you
uh are you the one that uh stated that
uh Pete hex who's going to be the next
dood would be
amenable to getting involved with this
or am I have I got a different bill that
might that would be the defend the
gville I believe but hey he might be on
board this too so we'll see yeah that he
designated DOD Chief defensive uh
defense department secretary heg Seth uh
that that had to do with defend the
guard which is HB 104 thank you uh
former representative thank you everyone
and with that uh I will call an end to
that hearing uh I do want to say that
the Admiral McCain that uh
representative gagy referred to in his
earlier reading I believe is a father of
of John McCain correct okay at this time
we have one more measure this morning
that would be hcf eight the
uh
the concurrent resolution rep
representative Barton um is is he still
here yes he
is
um that should have been in the um
package
thank you so I didn't see representative
guy being at the beginning of the
hearings do you remember when he came in
um yeah he can confirm he
okay the chair rep uh recognizes the
prime
sponsor that would be representative Bon
for house concurrent resolution 8 a
concurrent resolution is one that goes
to the Senate as opposed to an HR which
is strictly a house resolution this a
concurrent resolution urging Congress to
find that the pascao river and the port
Smith Harbor lie within the state of New
Hampshire so welcome representative
Barton and um have at it as I say chman
um so you may or may not know that um I
think it was under um Governor Lynch u a
similar resolution was passed in 2005 so
this is like the 20y year
anniversary um I I worked at Portsmith
Naval Shipyard for 16 almost 16 years
and uh this was a a highly contentious
issue and I happen to have read the uh
the entire um report that was uh
produced from Senator Bob Smith which I
have here and I'd like to to submit
unfortunately it's 85 pages I only have
one copy um I'd like to talk about this
um but before I do the the differences
between that 2005 resolution
and my proposed resolution the language
is exactly the same with one exception I
asked the um or I I included language to
ask the president of the United States
to issue an executive order to change
the duty stations of those service
members and employees at Portsmouth
Naval Shipyard from KY Maine properly to
Portsmouth New Hampshire um and uh I
think that's attainable um so I hope
that we could put this resolution um
through and it might have a little bit
of teeth I have copies of that original
um hc4 I think it was a a joint yeah hc4
from 2005 if the the committee members
want a copy I can pass that
around um now i' I'd like to get into
some of the um the parts of this this
report and some of the uh the issues uh
some history and background of of the
Border dispute um as I know it and in
reading the this report um and looking
at the
1977 um uh court case where uh it
established um the boundary of or or the
separation of the fishing Lanes from the
mouth of the piscatqua out to the um IA
scholes um that's all that was
established there when um New Hampshire
took issue with Maine saying hey the
shipyard and Badger Island they belong
to us because Maine was saying it's the
middle of the of the river well that
wasn't that wasn't established in that
decision um when it went to the Supreme
Court though the Supreme Court cited um
judicial aaple saying it was already
decided in this case they didn't
separate um the mouth of the river out
to the middle of the ocean from the
actual River in in land um according to
the documentation that was gathered uh
by Senator Smith's uh Team the um the
proper boundary of New Hampshire goes to
the high water mark on the main side so
we own all of the including all islands
and and and um small islands and all of
that stuff belongs to New Hampshire um
unfortunately Congress has to establish
that and it's never actually been
concretely established so so the
resolution also asks our congressionals
to um take uh legislative action but I I
think again issuing an executive order
could uh correct some of the um uh the
tax situation of the service members and
the um the federal employees at
Portsmouth Naval Shipyard um so I will
also submit uh and I have it
electronically but I'll submit this copy
of of that report
and uh finally I have um another piece
of evidence um this A A peculiar uh um
document that I've I obtained um while
working at the shipyard it's not
confidential or anything it's a it's a
position description uh from 19 uh
98 um an of8 is the form type and on
this
form um it was originally says a duty
station of uh Portsmouth New Hampshire
here and it was it was lined out and
handwritten uh
K
so you know for the longest time the
shipyard was always the shipyard
considered itself to be part of uh uh
Portsmith New Hampshire and properly so
but I would submit this document also
for what it's worth I don't know why it
was pen and ined and it was not properly
revised
um with that I'll take any questions
thank you rep representative Barton uh
very interesting so we're looking for
the president of the United States to do
an executive order correct uh yes Mr
chairman and there was a precedent there
was a previous 2005 uh resolution and
what was the resolution to that
resolution what what it it it was passed
with overwhelming bipartisan support so
I I expect this resolution to also pass
uh you know maybe we can have a 20-year
anniversary party uh to pass this
resolution and reaffirm our our position
on our boundry and uh and maybe actually
get something done for those um those
New Hampshire citizens that that uh work
and serve at the
shipyard thank you other questions for
the prime represent Mand bom uh thank
you Mr chairman so um representative Bon
just for the record I want to make sure
I have this correct would you say that
the L language in this continuing
resolution is the same as the 2005
resolution with the exception that the
new resolution posits that the Portsmith
naal Shipyard lives in Portsmith not
KY um I I think the language is exactly
the same except for the request okay um
even even and I I have it here if you
want to compare I have I have the 2005
resolution right here if you want I can
pass it around should I pass it around
that might be used
uh if you could give the clerk a copy of
the previous one before you go any other
questions for the prime I um about the
um thanks for taking my question um but
um about the 85 page document is that um
online anywhere or can um we I don't
know if we have the abilities with our
clerk to scan that or I possibly I found
it in in a box that was going to be
tossed out while working at the shipyard
I think in like
2010 and I recognized it at at as that
report it's not classified or anything
like that so I'm I made a copy I did
scan it in myself um but you're welcome
to do whatever you like with with this
copy it's very very informative do we
have the abilities to do that possibly
so we have that
information yes I'm sure that uh uh
Davis the the uh scan there's a scan
capability here at the uh leg Yeah our
researcher can help with that that thank
you thank you thank you representative
Barton saying no other the hands uh we
have two more
cards
uh udis James if I said that
correctly is is uh is Mr James if that's
if that is a he
is not seeing him I have one other card
uh Mark ster from Portsmith has asked
for 10 minutes
uh up to 10 minutes 10 minutes or less
uh there he is welcome Mr statner from
Portsmouth so that's right in your
neighborhood this my first time speaking
before anyone in the Hampshire
government so forgive me if I don't know
the protocols and how it
happens uh so I'd like to tell you a
little bit about the background so you
know what it consists of I graduated
from Sunni Maritime College State
University of New York Merchant Marine
Academy I graduated with a bachelor of
Engineering in Naval
architecture I also graduated with a US
Coast card third mates license unlimited
tonnage
oceans I'm also a because of that
license I'm a master or Captain 100 ton
and 200 ton Chief mate
my first uh job was working at military
sea lift command as a naval architect in
Washington
DC then I transferred in 1999 to
portsman Naval
Shipyard I was employed as a naval
architect senior Naval architect at
Portsmouth Naval Shipyard from about
1999 till I recently retired December
31st of this year I've lived through
through this I have firsthand knowledge
I have experience and background on the
issue and I've put together some key
points that I'd like to go over with you
some of them may have been touched on
with by
Joe if they've been touched on already
uh you don't need to repeat them um so
uh sure you just to keep things keep
things rolling sure the Supreme Court
never decided the boundary between Maine
and
Hampshire the only line between between
the Hampshire and Maine is a fishing
rights line that goes from the entrance
of Portsmouth Harbor to gospo Harbor to
settle a lobster dispute that's it there
is no boundary from the mouth of
portsman Harbor up the river ever
established by
Congress I have a nordal chart which I
laid it out which might be easier to see
if I only made one copy of all my
information so I'd like to submit
this good good the clerk would love to
put that into our folder sure all right
Shipyard workers have been unlawfully
taxed by Maine since the
1970s this happened because some
controller who worked at the shipyard
and lived in Maine unilaterally changed
the duty station and Duty
location on that form that Joe presented
to you for all the shipyard
workers from Portsmouth Naval Shipyard
Duty station and Duty location to kid
main what happened when that's
changed M get Maine now has the ability
to tax the shipyard workers because it's
reported as income to
main I estimated that I personally
as a portsman New Hampshire resident
gave over
$100,000 of my income to the state of
Maine
unlawfully let's multiply that by the
thousands of Shipyard
workers since this happened we're
talking hundreds of millions of dollars
are going to
Maine that money lawfully should be at
the disposal of New Hampshire
residents estimated $5,000 a year for
every single New Hampshire resident
whether you're Democrat Republican
whatever your affiliation is that's
better spent here that's better spend
doing whatever going to spending on
businesses paying for child support
whatever than going to main illegally
this is hundreds of millions of dollars
here hundreds okay
um settling this matter would boost the
Hampshire's
economy for the employees be free to
spend this income in New Hampshire if
they
choose the president of the United
States can declare
slir that the duty station and the duty
location is Portsmouth New
Hampshire this is legal right of the
executive branch to do so
changing that one line on those SF uh
actually o8s they're called instantly
cuts off Maine from getting our
income and the Hampshire residents don't
have to give it to Maine now if you're a
Maine resident of course you're still
going to pay main income taxes but New
Hampshire residents won't now let's take
talk about how unfair this is right
now typically property tax in New
Hampshire are
twice those in Maine because we don't
have an income tax is one of the reasons
so as a shipyard worker living in New
Hampshire I'm paying double the property
taxes and I'm paying main income tax
three okay it's not cheap living here
anymore so that's a big
problem
um since as another issue is enforcement
of Maritime laws since there's no
defined border it's impossible from
reinforcement to enforce voting
laws okay if someone's in an accident
because they're intoxicated and somebody
loses their life or there's a casualty
whatever in the middle of pisc in the
piscatqua
river what jurisdiction are the
under nobody
knows that's a problem
so this is the same issue as 20 years
ago but it's
different back then the Supreme Court
was not the proper venue to take this to
from what I've read the proper venue is
urging Congress to fix the Border
dispute resolve it once and for all
short-term
fix president or directs someone to
change Duty station Duty location so
immediate medely the taxes are going not
to main for the Hampshire residents but
are staying that salary staying in the
Hampshire short-term fix long-term fix
Congress fixes the
border now this is nothing new as far as
this dispute it's been going on for a
while when I was working at the shipyard
every time there was a news article what
I did is I printed it gathered them all
together and found them all and I
stapled them all
together it would be a really good idea
for this committee to look over these
news
articles can we can we have them Absolut
I only have one copy so that's why I
brought them for you we don't want to
take your only copy but we no you can if
that's for us that would be great yes
absolutely um I know how to find them uh
back online so I could resurrect him
again so um I'm really praying that this
committee passes this
resolution
it's going to make a huge difference now
uh for New Hampshire residents that work
at the shipyard because the cost of real
estate I couldn't afford to live in
Portsmouth now if I wanted to I'm lucky
I bought my house 20 years ago but 25
now but that little extra well not
little but that thousands of dollars
extra those new hires and those people
that are just living paycheck to
paycheck that money can help them out
instead of going to Maine where it
doesn't do anything for them understand
what you what you've said about the uh
the taxes and the money um anything else
um no I'm open to any questions that
this committee has are there any
questions representative
Bennett thank you for taking my question
um I'm a little unclear as to was it at
what point point you said it was
somebody somewhere just changed it
arbitrarily so do you have a time where
it was the Portsmith Naval Shipyard and
then when it changed like I can't
imagine that many people waking up one
day and oh the address has changed and
it wasn't a problem can you explain a
little bit more about that process so
what I understood happened is a com trol
for the shipyard who happened to live in
Maine realized hey uh the shipyard made
the decision himself or herself I don't
know hey uh you know uh it's in Maine
they got to cross a bridge to get here
it's a main so they're not paying main
income taxes and he started this person
started changing all those
PDS from portsman Naval Shipyard and the
duty station to kidy Maine then all of a
sudden the form the government form had
main on it which triggered main income
taxes good history there and also it's
interesting what Joe B Barton pointed
out is it was sluggish there's all these
different PDS you might have a secretary
you might have an engineer you might
have this and that it took quite a while
for them to slowly change the
paperwork but it was originally portsman
Nao Shipyard for Duty station and Duty
location for a long long time wouth not
KY Naval Station correct other questions
see representative mandle
bomb thank you Mr chairman um so Mr ster
um have you spoken with anyone at the
Port SM Naval Shipyard about this bill
and gotten their their their view on it
I have not spoken to Porta Shipyard
about this bill but I will say one thing
why does the federal government
care okay the reason why I say that is
because apparently if you're in a
leadership position and you happen to
live in Maine you do care because they
feel that they're going to have to pay
higher main income taxes if they lose
the
Hampshire if you so they even though the
main budget is huge they're afraid of
maybe having to pay a dollar or two
extra taxes that they don't have
to as a granted stator I like your math
and uh and I I think uh Ron manam asked
a good question um and we'll have some
time to do some research on our own
before we EXA this uh my gut feeling U
is a resolution that's kind of pro New
Hampshire would would find favor here
but uh I don't want to get ahead of
myself other questions seeing No Hands
thank you sir Mr s and with that I will
uh end the hearing
on H hcr8 uh we're going to recess at
this time until 1: p.m. when our next
scheduled measure is going to happen um
I'm going to ask um the uh folks on the
on the blue team we're looking to have a
uh a caucus uh the red team folks we had
a couple people coming in to talk to us
so if you could uh excuse us until 1
p.m. uh we have an office if if uh R
side if few see cyber if if you want to
uh hang out in our office uh or whatever
space I know if you want to get together
with your folks uh we're not going to
exec anything this afternoon but we did
have a caucus schedule so we're going to
do that at this time so we'll see
everybody back at 100 pm. and whoever's
on the fourth floor uh uh running the
video as we go to our caucus uh you can
feel free to turn the video off I'm sure
you'll do that anyway and we'll see
everybody at 1 pm. thank you
okay uh welcome back everyone to uh we
have one measure this
afternoon uh and that measure is hr11
house resolution 11 a resolution urging
the United States government to
investigate allegations of abuse of
minorities especially Hindus Buddhists
Christians and other religious
minorities by the interim government of
Bangladesh so that uh is a very
interesting uh HR that we're going to
hear about the prime sponsor is our
colleague uh representative Abul Khan of
Rockingham 30 uh representative KH
welcome great to see you here looking
forward to uh your presentation your
introduction so uh so
welcome sorry thank you Mr chairman
member of the committee my colleag
colleages uh before I start my thing uh
I'm just coming off with all of you the
testimony of uh
256 I was glad that I was here for that
testimony and um I have to uh salute all
of you that serve for our country United
States of America all the veterans here
in the committee and anybody in the
present please take my salute
thank you for that representative thank
you thank you again you know from my
heartful you know thanks for that your
service um um honorable chairman
honorable member of the committee I am
uh your colleague Abul Bean representing
CBR for the sixth term I'm here before
you to ask about my native country
Bangladesh where I was born 65 years ago
uh next month I immigrated to United
States date 45 years ago on January 10th
of this month 10 days before Ronald ran
took
office since that time I had many friend
relatives living in Bangladesh and I was
a frequent visitor of my birth country
last August 5th of
2024 many things changed in that
beautiful country a fundamental
fundamentalist group with the student
Uprising took over the country's power
and installed a
noble larat larat named Dr Eunice since
that time the country has been in
turmoil lots of targeted attack on
religious minorities and political Oppo
opposition in their homes businesses and
religious places the government is not
taking any step to stop this kind of
violence on November 25th a well-known
Hindu religion leader chinmoy Krishna
Dash was arrested and detained without
any due process of law without any Bell
his fault was he was a vocal regarding
minority rights the government alleged
that uh he disrespected the Bangladeshi
flag which is not considered a big crime
in the real world my colleagues I'm
urging you please approve the resolution
and stand with all the minority
religious people
of the world show them we are with them
and ask the united state government to
take stand and investigate those
allegation and thank you very much and
what I'm doing Mr chairman and my
colleagues that doing so what I you know
before you I might not be able to go to
my native country ever again if that
government stays in the power so please
I'm urging you that you know you take a
appropriate action and um I am not a
person that U file bills left and right
if you can see my record if it is not
did not hit my heart and if it is not a
issue that it can affect the my living
on the the country I live the country we
all live it can come to
hear as a fundamentalist that that is
you know a country Bangladesh it has one
173 million people and the and the the
area is like our state called Wisconsin
know that kind of small area has a lot
of people and lots of lots of
fundamentalists Islamic fundamentalists
they are in Rising they could you know I
I don't want to use the terrorist
because we need to see it but that is
the breeding ground for that that is the
breeding ground for that we living in
United State we have we need to do
something about it anywhere in the world
that that kind of Rise is going and we
know we are suffering every day thank
you Mr chairman thank you board member
for listening to
me thank you representative uh would you
take any questions
or I'm sorry Mr chairman I forgot I'm so
nervous I forgot that I have to ask that
if I'm ready to I will take as many
question Mr chairman I apologize there
uh people are often nervous when they uh
when they testify as we all know
um so a couple of things what I'm
hearing from you is that the current the
latest government in Bangladesh is a
fundamentalist would you say they're a
theocracy uh a
fundamentalist uh theocracy in the sense
of like Iran is a theocracy is is that
fair to say is that
accurate that's a great question Mr
chairman so let me explain to you so
when this fundamentalist student
Uprising happened and the most of them
came from madrasas in in Late July and
early August they are all madrasa
student you know what is madrasha means
right that's a institution col schools
and colleges teaches Islamic you know
ideas and you know things teachings they
all came from those madas and they
overthrow the duly elected
government and it was big uprising and
government could not do anything a lot
of people died and in the process also
and they put a interm government with
the um uh Chief
advisor who his name is Dr yunus and
then they have a bunch of advisers and
Dr yunus was in
overseas he's a u and he came to you
know they brought him in put him on the
chief advisor and all all other advisers
are fundamentalist Islamic
fundamentalist they're related to all
the uh band organization called jamat
Islam and other Islamic organization
that they are banned in United State and
other countries so at this time the
price of product in people are in very
bad shape you know the they could not
control they are not controlling
anything there is no Law and Order
people are uh facing all kind of
bad things happening to them you know in
a peaceful country before August
5th thank you representative just a
little bit of context so when you were
born uh your country at that time was
East Pakistan correct no Mr Mr chairman
I was born yes you are right I was born
in 1960 it was East Pakistan 1971 is
when there was a there was a so so where
were you were born now Bangladesh was
then East Pakistan you're right and the
uh so not everybody perhaps remembers
I'm old enough to remember that that war
so in 1971 East Pakistan uh basically
seceded left the country of Pakistan and
became Bangladesh correct in 1971 so Mr
chairman if I may explain a little bit
more yeah please that would be great for
us toar
so when the India divided in
1947 or you know maybe 1949 I cannot
exactly so the India divided it became
India today's India and then Pakistan
and Pakistan divided two but it's one
country East Pakistan and West Pakistan
and uh they had a geographical uh
differences about 1,000 miles in between
East and West Pakistan but it was one
government so we were we had problem
with the West Pakistan because they are
holding the power and everything so we
went to Freedom fight in
1971 and with the help of
India uh within 9 months we became uh
independent country it was a lot of
Bloodshed about 3 million people died
it's about 30 million people went to
India as a refugee Refugee and many of
you remember that U the The Beatles had
a concert in New York in a men Square
Garden and you know many things happen
in
1971 since then you know we have
different government different you know
things still it was not like today's
fundamentalism you know it was a popular
government was not some government was
not popular and many some government has
a full democracy some government didn't
had have democracy and all kind of
things in underdeveloped countries like
any other underdeveloped countries but
now is the things that were you know is
going in a different direction that
Islamic
fundamentalism is the main thing in the
government is it fair to say that before
this recent regime
change that Bangladesh was fair had a
measure of uh of Tolerance uh religious
tolerance religious freedom is it is
that fair to say there was more there
was some measure of religious freedom
before the regime change is that
accurate Mr chairman that is another
very good question um um the the past
government uh she was the daughter of
our Founding Father Of The Nation Sheik
mujibur
ramman and she she held the government
for 15 years and because she
was supported by the minorities she was
she had lot of support from the
minorities and she supported the
minority she
put minorities only 11% 10 or 11% in all
the minorities and they
are they're not getting any before heart
they're not getting any good job good
education and all these thing and she
put all those minorities in a good
places you know wherever she can and now
this government taking out those
minorities they're losing their jobs you
know the last government put all the
minorities in a good good
place she took care of minorities very
very
well thank you for that uh other
questions for representative Khan uh yes
representative Manion thank you Mr CH
thanks for taking my question would you
say that uh the outcome of this could
potentially lead to like Regional
instability with uh L Refugee
crisis um
um thank you representative you know
that for that question yes uh this
government also very much big time anti-
India so India is a you know in our
subcontinent that region is a superpower
you know they are the leader in our so
the last government we had very good
relation with
India this government is to anti- India
because the Hindus are the majority in
India that's why they are up mean after
Hindus you know in Bangladesh because
the India doesn't support this
government this inter government and
this fake government so it can go all
different ways it can you know send all
kind it can create many many terrorist
it can have a refugee problem in again
in India a lot of refugee can can go to
India and other uh neighboring countries
and other many many bad thing can
happen thank
you other
questions uh representative
Jones well thank you Mr chair and thank
you representative for being here um
question on one word in your bill urg
United States government to investigate
allegations and why that word
allegations cuz that means something
allegedly happened wouldn't it be more
better to put the word incidence in
there uh when we wrote the Bill and when
um
uh I if if the committee would choose to
do that I have no problem but I think
that uh uh we are at this time the
reason I said allegation is I'm we are
asking the government to see if it is
true so it is for me you know I I wanted
to go soft way and you know to
accommodate everybody that was the
reason I put allegations you know that
makes sense then thank
you thank you represent Jones I point
out is you probably all know that once a
committee receives a measure a bill or a
resolution that the committee can owns
that and can amend it so uh we could
maybe word Smith that uh I hadn't
thought of that but that's a a good a
good point other questions
representative from Dunbarton thank you
Mr chair thanks for taking my question
um so it's my understanding that
Bangladesh is a member of the United
Nations has the United Nations addressed
this in any form of resolution as far as
the atrocities you're describing
happening there currently so what I know
that United Nations as we speak they are
investigating also that what happened to
the minority is but many time United
Nations in my sense that when they go
accompanied by the current government
they don't see the real uh picture of it
you know like any United Nations
investigation we know living in United
States it does not go too far you I
don't have to tell you you all know it
does not go far enough to see real
picture you know
follow
up follow up are there currently UN
peacekeepers in the country of
Bangladesh no no uh there is no un UN
peacekeepers in in Bangladesh at this
time other
questions rep
cyber thank you for taking my question
um I had a quick um it's just a
observation I guess I want to thank
everyone for being here um I fully
understand I have a lot of ancestors um
that came here um you know for the
purpose of having you know religious
freedom um and so you know a lot of them
had been you know persecuted and killed
and and of that sort so um a little bit
of um you know commonality there um I
fully agree with this measure um one
thing I did want to point out though is
just um I understand a lot of um America
has a lot of ignorance when does come to
Islam sometimes is there a minority um
sect of like Islams that are of the
Islamic faith that are being persecuted
as well since it's obviously more of the
fundamentalist side and should we maybe
add that
in so in my knowledge um I if I
understand your question right I think
you're saying that there is a religious
act called sh sh uh I do not heard that
they are having any issue with this
government or you know um
or anything you know I think they they
are okay you know in my knowledge I I do
not know but everything is going towards
Hindus mainly the reason is
anti-india you know the the Hindus are
the majority population in India and the
last government the elected government
was very very close friend with India so
everything is going towards Hindus and
it's it's really really
alarming to follow up on representative
saber's question I'm curious uh the Unos
government um are they uh you know if
they are Shia Sunni are they aligned
with the um either of those sects the
Shia or Sunni
100% Sunni
okay and that would be the Saudi the
Saudi Arabian type of uh is
Islamic is let me ask you this now that
I know that there are Sunni if that's
clear has Saudi Arabia uh or countries
like that Sunni countries have they
recognized this Unos
government um I I don't have that
information Mr chairman I can tell
you okay yeah just just I I just have to
say that Saudi AR Arabia also equally
guilty of all these things because they
pumped millions of million dollars for
years and years for making those
madrasas they want you know all this
area that Muslim countries that they
have the Islamic teaching so they be
becomes what they wanted you know they
want to do in in the world in their
ideology okay thank you for that other
questions yes representative
Buddha uh thank you uh representative
for taking my question so the ongoing
political instability in Bangladesh as
highlighted uh in this resolution raises
uh concerns about its potential impact
on Regional instability and US interest
Bangladesh plays a strategic role in
South
Asia um sharing borders with India and
Myanmar and serving as a key partner in
in economy economic and security
initiatives prolonged unrest could lead
to crossborder tensions Refugee crisis
economic disruptions and challenges
encountering um extremism all of which
may affect or affect us strategic
interest in the region so my question to
you is Sir are you concerned are there
concerns that the situation in
Bangladesh could escalate impacting
Regional stability and US interest
particularly in terms of security trade
and humanitarian
sectors thank you uh representative
that's another great question yes as you
can see and if you read other newspaper
article last few weeks especially last
couple of weeks they are already having
lot of um um um in incidents in the
border between India and
Bangladesh and there some incidents I
hear also in the barage border that
happening as we speak you know in last
few weeks especially the Indian
Bangladesh border lot of bad things
happening right now you know where I saw
it in the newspaper program newspaper
articles and the TV programs you know
and it can go beyond you know you know
in a bad situation also uh the United
States interest we want to let everybody
live peacefully in their own thing we
live here in United States we do not
want to see any terrorism raise up
anywhere in the world you know that is
our number one goal you know we let live
live peacefully and we want to be in
peaceful also so Bangladesh is a
breeding ground for something bad can
happen you know especially Islamic
fundamentalism and terrorism
followup
followup um has there been any research
or report done by uh Human Rights Watch
or Amnesty International or Freedom
watch Freedom House on these allegation
so representative this is only we
talking about five months in five months
a government can go syn how deep that is
a pro problem you know the the the the
market product is went up at least
uh 40% between 30 40 50% of the product
uh it's it's in a turmoil you know
people don't have enough income lot we
we are very well known for our garment
industry it's about 200 garments closed
up because they don't have um money or
resources to run the garments and those
200 garments employees are out of work
I'm just giving you one sector and and
um the the other uh Industries like uh
many other Industries because it was uh
it was either burned or destroyed by the
this Uprising in August 5th between
August 5th and August uh 10th they
looted many many places and the economy
is in a real turmoil
situation thank you for thank
you representative if this should get
through this committee would you be
willing to speak to it on the house
floor yes Mr chairman I
will okay that takes some of the
pressure off of of of I think you you'd
be a very appropriate spokesperson to uh
speak to the full house uh thank you for
that uh if it gets to that point other
questions represent
Rollins thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my question are you able to
communicate with anyone of any of your
family members back in Bangladesh or is
allun communication stock no
communication is still on it's it's it's
no problem we can see talk and
everything what I'm saying make no
mistake what I'm doing right now in this
table in front of you after today my
life will be in Jeopardy if I go
there I'm not I'm not kiding or I'm not
you know
saying other questions repr Manion this
might be a hypothetical but like uh us
uh US Government tends to be uh have it
its fingers in a lot of like regime
change that occurs around the planet do
you know if there's any big backer
behind this type of regime change
whether it be China Iran or or Russia
representative great great questions I
didn't want it because my colleagues
here is we are Democrats we are
Republicans you know we all accommodate
each other and everything this
government the Dr yunus was very close
with Clinton Foundation I didn't want to
bring that because Clinton Foundation is
well known he is one of the big found
riser for Clinton foundation
and whatever he was doing
before this government took over in the
United States 5 days ago he was doing
many many crazy thing but then since
this
government is is lot little bit less
because uh uh he his power and the last
Biden Administration is gone I didn't
want to bring that because we all you
know so that is another
thing other questions for the prime
sponsor sign thank you representative
Khan thank you very much all my
colleagues thank you I have three other
cards all asking for five minutes um
Ashish K Deb Ashish welcome
thank you Mr
chairman honorable chairman and The
Honorable members of the sfr and VA
committee gentlemen good afternoon my
name is Ashish
Deb I have
been living in the Greater Boston area
since May
1988 I came to this country as a student
in
1980 and did my
undergraduate not undergraduate my
Master's and PhD at Syracuse
University by profession I am a software
engineer and in 1988 I started
my professional life with Wang
Laboratories perhaps most of you are
familiar with this
name and since then I have been
working in various it companies in
Greater Boston
area let me first thank you for giving
us an
opportunity to tell about the violence
and atrocities against the religious
minorities including Hindus Christian
Buddhist and also some minorities
Islamic sects in Bangladesh after the
fall of sha
ha's government
in in uh August 5
2024 please note that Shak hass's
government was elected democratically in
January
2024 the fall of the government started
with the student lad protest
to reform the job quotas reserved for
the families of the veterans of the 1971
Liberation War the government was also
sympathetic to the cause of the students
protest and requested the court to
reform the government job cotas in order
to make it fairer and acceptable to all
concerned parties although the students
request was largely mad by the court the
protest soon trans formed into a wider
anti-government movement nobody knew at
that time now it is clear that some
invisible Powers were working behind the
so-called student protests which was led
by few student
coordinators were none but the students
from the Muslim madrasas where they were
indoctrinated by the Islamic rules and
laws on August
5 prime minister hassina left the
country with the help of country's
military as violence Rose to its aex
consequently what began as celebration
quickly spiraled into violent violent
unrest with riers targeting the
supporters of Shak hass's aami League
party and religious minorities
while some say minority are largely
viewed as supporters of shik hass's
party others point out some economic and
mostly the religious Factor Behind these
attacks on August 8 2024 an interim
government was formed with the dozens of
advisers who have no experience in
governing the country and it was headed
by Professor Muhammad eunus as Chief
adviser who also had no political
experience to run a
country many of you must have heard
about Professor unus who is a banker and
head of the gramine bank he also
received Nobel Prize in 2006 along with
the gramine bank the interim government
consistently denied the occurrence of
such attacks and atrocities against the
religious
minorities especially the Hindus the
interim government has no control over
the Law and Order however after
concerns on the safety of the religious
minorities raised by the government of
India the interim government issued
statement acknowledging some attacks on
homes temples shrines and dorgas and
other places of worships of the
religious
minorities however the interim
government did nothing to stop the
violence which is still continuing
throughout the country
the interim government not only put its
blind eyes on all the atrocities and
violence that have been committed
against the religious minorities but
also imprisoned the leaders of the
religious minorities who protested
against all these
violences it falsely accused a Hindu
monk named chinmo Krishna dash for
treason and put him in jail without
providing any lawyer to plea for his
bail
the Jihadi lawyers warned openly to kill
anyone who would plea for Mr das's baay
Mr Das is still in jail and his bail was
denied by the judges who are either
condoning the jihadist activities or are
afraid of
them The Only Fault of Mr Das was that
he led large Ries demanding safety for
the Hindus and other
minorities many in the inter government
saw that the large rallies by
Hindus
were a threat to the stability to the
government uh to the inter government
and they also thought it's a PL to
rehabilitate
Shea and her AI League
party let us quote a recent comment on
acts against the
violence uh
against the religious violence against
the religious minorities especially
Hindus in Bangladesh by Tuli gabard who
has been nominated for the director of
intelligence by President
Trump she said quote it broke my heart
to see such hate and violence being
directed towards devotees of God in
their temples in Bangladesh for this
jihadist to believe that it is a
pleasing to God to burn and destroy the
temples and shows how
far uh and uh sorry temples and the
Morty of such a saintly person that is
divine grace
Asami prup this just shows how far away
from God they really are she continues
God is love and his true
servants and Man true governs embody and
manifest the love in the world now is
the time for supposedly secular
government of Bangladesh to protect the
country's religious minorities including
Hindus Christian Buddhist from the
jihadist forces of hate
unquote honorable members if you are
interested to learn more
about the challenges religious
minorities are facing in Bangladesh
you
can look at the report prepared by The
Minority Rights group International
titled under threat the challenges
facing religious minorities in in
Bangladesh I gave the link in my
statement a copy of which you
have numerous clips of violence and
atrocities against the religious
minorities currently occurring in
Bangladesh can be found by searching
YouTube or Google it's an irony that
none of the media Outlets newspapers
radio or TV channels can show these
violences as they are fully controlled
by the interim government so the social
media is the only
source we are deeply troubled and
worried by the current situation in
Bangladesh due to the following reasons
the complete deterioration of the rule
of law and Democratic principles serious
violations of human rights women are
facing harassment and discrimination
minorities are persecuted and their home
places of worships are either burned or
demolished students teachers Headmasters
College principles
professors University faculty who used
to be a liberal and maybe sympathetic to
the previous government are forced to
resign and without any due
process political leaders from the
previous government are being targeted
Nationwide their houses are burned and
they are physically tortured and even
killed local Administration police and
military appear to be not in
control or don't want to mess up with
the so-called student mob who think they
can do anything after they were
successful in overthrowing the previous
government the daily lives of numerous
peac loving families in Bangladesh
including many of our relatives loved
ones and friends are now lived with fear
some are hiding and some even remain
awake at night fearing attacks on them
at any
time we presumed and now it is clear
that the fanatic Islamic fundamentalist
groups and parties are behind all these
they are attempting to change
Bangladesh's national anthem and flag
they allegedly burned the home of the
Nations Founding Father destroyed or
demolished the symbols of Bangladesh's
Liberation War sculptures statues
museums and even libraries it appears
that their only objective is to destroy
the spirit of Bangladesh Liberation War
forever and change or rewrite the
history in their own way
the current interim government and the
press for some reason condone or remain
silent on these events we firly believe
if this situation continues without any
check Bangladesh could become a breeding
ground of religious extremism like we
saw in
Afghanistan the that all on on one
account is more than 10 folds since the
interim government took power than
before the resignation of of the
previous government it is really ironic
that a recipient of the Nobel Peace
Prize who is heading this interim
government doing everything but
maintaining peace Law and Order someon
raising questions about his sincerity
and thinking now is the time to call for
revoking his revoking his Nobel Peace
Prize you are our elected leaders so we
ARG you to present Our concern to the US
Senate Foreign Relations Committee or
even to the US state department so that
the government do whatever means they
have to bring about peace Justice and
democracy in Bangladesh in order for
general public including religious
minorities going about their lives
without any fear of being harassed
tortured or even killed we will always
stand with you in your part suit of a
future better future for Humanity to
Live Free or Die thank you very much
thanks for G giving me time extra time
to read my statement thank you I'm open
to take any questions please thank you
Mr Deb for offering to take questions
Live Free or Die is something that
resonates uh with most of us in this
state uh I don't mind having you use
that phrase you mention YouTube and
Google uh you may or may not know as I
mentioned to an earlier group uh these
proceedings these hearings are are
recorded and televised and available on
YouTube and okay I think that the case
that representative Khan and you are
making uh for people that are interested
in that uh the uh recording might be of
great value my question uh is with
regard to the previous leader who you
said left on August 9th August uh 5th
August 5th okay where where did they go
go she went to India okay so she is in
India at this time the previous she is
India India she got political Asylum not
political Asylum she
is protected by the Indian government
and she is in a secret place because
India thinks that this fundamentalist
could if she is around and everybody
knows where she is staying then it is
risk to her life believe me this
fundamentalist that are in Bangladesh
right now they are helped by the
Pakistani
isi
uh these are the
uh not they are doing all those things
around uh in Afghanistan in Bangladesh
in India they are breeding they buing
terrorist and sending it to different
countries to do all those things so
thises the previous leader aspire to
return Yes uh she she she she is willing
to return and um and most of the analyst
think that if India get
involved uh which is Bangladeshi interim
government or this fundamentalist group
they are provoking India to get into
war uh the my friend that you know
mentioned that there are lot of uh
disturbances going along the borders it
is intentionally being done the people
from Bangladesh they are going inside
India cutting their crops and taking it
to Bangladesh there are several places
maybe miles that there is no uh fences
and if the if India wants to put the
fence then the people from Bangladesh go
there and try to make a problem you know
they're they're fighting with the uh
border security force of India so we
mentioned earlier that until 1971
Bangladesh was East Pakistan which uh no
before 19 right right until 1971 it was
East Pakistan since 1947 yeah where
representative Khan touched on that
and in 1971 East Pakistan uh separated
from Pakistan and became Bangladesh so
my question is what is the posture of
Pakistan formerly West Pakistan but
Pakistan has Pakistan recognize this new
regime it's a it's a it's a very great
question because in
1971 India helped the Bangladeshi
Liberation forces to
you know fight the uh Pakistani soldiers
that they were staying there for 9
months uh India helped us and we got the
uh
Independence now Pakistan couldn't
forget these things and that's why they
have been trying to do all those things
behind the scene with the
Islamic uh parties that were defeated
because they didn't want the
independence of Bangladesh they wanted
to stay with Pakistan this jamaat
islami and
Pakistan uh secretly was helping them
that's our understanding and Pakistan
wants to take revenge against the India
because they think that India split this
country East Pakistan and West Pakistan
splitted it for their
advantage because if East Pakistan is a
separate country bengalis we have same
culture West Bengal which is the capital
is Kolkata and Daka is the capital of
East Pakistan used to be East Pakistan
West P East Pakistan and West Bengal of
India used to be one
state and the British rulers they knew
that the bengalis are the very uh
Progressive and these kind of people
they know if they stay together then it
will be a problem so so they divided the
Bengal and one become East Bengal the
other was West bangal so does Pakistan
have diplomatic relations with the new
bang they used to yes with old old uh
government they used to have but not
that way currently Dr unus Professor
unus is out of the country he is
attending the economic Summit AT Davos
Switzerland and there is nobody and we
heard the news that the uh chairman of
the isi which is a detective branch of
Pakistani government uh like you know
you can say CIA uh that are visiting
Pakistan uh sorry Bangladesh and they
are meeting with the military so we are
thinking that they are plotting
something
maybe a military coup or something I
don't know those kind of things so yes
there is a
relation which is we don't know how much
but uh between isi and this Islamic
jihadist parties and groups in
Bangladesh okay thank you question other
questions for Mr Deb uh representative
Bennett thank you for taking my question
um do you think that there are people
or do you know if there are people from
coming from your country to America for
political Asylum at this time are they
able to get out of the country for
danger reasons uh I don't know about
this but I know that most of the uh many
of the people who had the opportunity
you have the opportunity either they
have the Visas previous visas from us or
from other countries they're living the
country for their safety because they
couldn't see normal people cannot live
in the country right now because
yesterday I saw a video that a a student
presumably student came out of a you
know taxi and a group of another
students was beating him with X and
hurting his ankle and knees severely and
uh and he died and he died right in
front daylight in the street nobody is
going there everybody is avoiding
because they think that if they want to
stop the people or they go there for
help they will be attacked also so
nobody a normal person cannot stay there
if they have any way to coming like
students have visas they are coming out
of the country uh or going to Europe to
any country or here in the United States
but I uh don't know anybody that came
here uh after this or due to this and
ask for any Asylum no I don't know
represent cyber did you have your hand
up yeah I just had a quick question um
kind of an OB observation but it is a
question um so um in I guess the perfect
world where and and I really hope this
happens truly um to where you guys get
your your previous leader back or what
you I'm sure you guys probably still
consider her Your Leader you recognize
this yeah the new corrupt leaders um but
um with that said um do you believe it's
a better idea and would you in the
future then um have a strict policy of
separation of church and state so that
you don't have you know religious
institutions maybe running you know
state run schools and all that type of
thing yeah it's a very good question and
this separation of chch and government
is it it is possible in this environment
in the western world but in our country
uh everybody is very religious and we
don't have any problem with being
religious but it hurts us when religion
becomes so you know makes people so
fanatic when you become a fanatic you
cannot how can you kill a person by
beating him with ax on his knees and
ankles so that he cannot walk and and he
died in we saw in the
video last night you know after seeing
the video I couldn't sleep I knew that I
will come here but I couldn't sleep I
was thinking God which country it turned
into but under the previous government
government tried to make perhaps you
know that Bangladesh was doing very good
they came out of the third world
countries their GDP in most cases was
better than India and uh very good and
Sh wanted to make the
country first world country 20 something
she had she had some kind of vision and
she was doing
everything uh you know the
infrastructure wise she made lot of
things that are uh now we can say that
uh that we uh can could be in 10 20
years like Singapore or something that
was her vision but uh these people
burned lot of stuff that destroyed all
the documents that destroyed the Museum
of our Liberation war that destroyed the
sculpture that destroyed the statue of
our founding
father I don't know how they can do
that thank you for that Mr Deb uh very
useful Uh current contemporary issue
lesson today at least for me uh I'm
learning a lot other questions uh
representative buat budhi thank you
chairman um I'm just trying to
understand um so you are you
saying whatever is now happening in
Bangladesh about human rights abuses is
uh coming from uh the interim government
from Dr yunus Muhammad
yunice I don't know whether they from
the interim government but interim
government is condoning all those things
they their partners are this but let me
put it this way that his partner he is
from gramine Bank his only interest
which I see and many of us may see that
he was convicted for evading tax from
gaming bank and
666 cres of Bangladeshi takas was he was
supposed to give
back and uh August 7th or something was
the date of that final uh you know
um whatever you know conviction and all
those things against uh this uh
Professor unus but before that August
5th they did all those things to so that
H and the government can fall government
fall and all those things happened a
quick followup follow
up um so I'm just trying to strengthen
you know my thinking here so is it be is
it because of the advisers of Dr Unis or
entering government all these are
happening no I think he is also involved
in this it is clear because he was
denying that nothing is happening he is
not saying if you are a good person you
could at least go to the TV and radio
channels and tell that please don't do
this this is not good you cannot do this
he is a recipient of Nobel Peace Prize
why he couldn't say those things because
he's condoning all those
things and he is part of this
conspiracy the fall of the government my
friend told earlier that he is was uh
very aligned with the Clinton Foundation
let me point out one thing when he came
in last September in New York for this
General Assembly meeting he made a
meeting with Clinton foundation and you
can see it it is in YouTube he
introduced this Maul Alam there is one
person is his advisor as he told
President Clinton that this is the
person he designed he did a meticulous
design
that previous government didn't know who
is the student
leader and doing all those things and
and and and it was clear that it was the
this
um uh Revolution or this Uprising was
pre-planned and some people and somebody
maybe some invisible government was
helping them and the student
protest was just a PL just just
something that it's a sincere and it was
government was didn't know that is a
student
Uprising but after everything was made
from their
demand they started to say that okay now
we want the fall of the we don't want
this government because they killed us
and in fact
whoever was killed they were not killed
by the
police the I don't know how this
jihadist got the arms because all the
bullets that HD the students and they
died was never used by police in
Bangladesh the police Bangladeshi police
didn't use those bullets and these
bullets came from somewhere so we think
that they infiltrated in the police and
they used
these weapons coming from
somewhere and killed the students so
that they get the people's support
because they were killing you killed so
many people so we don't want this
government so we don't know where the
arms came from we don't know where they
from and it's the proof proof is there
and interim government is not doing
anything about this is not saying
anything understood understood other
questions say n we kept you for more
than your five minutes uh Mr Deb but uh
obviously we're very interested in
understanding what you're trying to have
us understand yes I have two more cards
uh Muhammad Safir R rakman chaeri thank
you did I get was that fairly close you
know we're looking for you yes yes sir
welcome thank you
chairman honorable chairman uh your
Excellency uh Mr M and
honorable uh state representatives and
fellow friends here uh good afternoon uh
it's an honor to be here uh myself
Mohammad saur Rahman CH and as known
tipu CH in my
Society uh first I'm
uh I'm from high respect from my side
and from my country this country and by
mades country Bangladesh and for this
resolution uh I think this is the time
burning issue and that's why we are here
what I believe uh I something whatever I
drafted here B said I have the privilege
of being a proud American citizen and my
mother's country in
Bangladesh that is why today I consider
myself uh fortunate to be present among
you on on the question of democratic and
religious rights and freedoms of the
soul and people of my country and to
give the give me the opportunity to
speak on behalf of the peoples of
Bangladesh in the contest uh of the HR
11 resolution and your committee New
Hampshire congression uh
delegations all of you
uh United State Secretariat and I would
like to draw my humble attention to
White House Press office and
president-elect Donald Trump and his
administration a lot of thing uh was
discussed here I don't like to repeat
and was time because of this I'd like to
first uh present
here on behalf of this uh
resolution what is the
allegation why I'm here
today uh
the
first I'd like to say freedom expression
the the the places Bangladesh right now
the freedom of expression human
rights freedom of religious practice and
practice and rights right to complain
and seek Justice of the people of
Bangladesh have been uh sned all media
have been seized and controlled
journalist and freedom of press have
been taken away the Judiciary and police
and the state institution have been
seized second thing the conspiracy uh
conspiracy to turn Bangladesh into a
radical um like The Fanatic State uh
whatever my friends try to explain here
the it was started uh because many of
you just ask about the question uh
before 1947 after 71 what happened when
Bangladesh was born one group they
didn't like our freedom Independence the
name of those group is the West Pakistan
jamaat
islami they have a wing in Bangladesh
when 71 1971 we we are fighting with uh
against Pakistan and they are active
they killed our millions of people they
helped Pakistani soldiers to like you
know the kill our freedom fighters they
raped our mother sisters and then we had
a fight and we own the
fight on the
time they are introduced in front of our
generation country
rajakar and
alad and those
are
uh the name of the uh the uh the group
is jamaat islami after that and second
term It Was Bangladesh got independence
and
1975 the father of the nation bangabandu
shik Muju
Rahman he was killed with his whole
family his wife his two son his uh two
daughter-in-law his brothers and his
nine years old child everybody killed at
a
time behind this conspiracy this group
was involved over
there and after that
1975 till 19
90 it was a long time to 21 years and
shik mujib and his daughters they
because of his two daughters they out of
the country thanks God they survived and
there's a big fight and lot of things
against this group 21 years after that
1996 she became as a democratic because
after the election she won the election
it was started there then we saw that
when as the student of the Chong
University I saw that I was uh because
of when my master's exam because my lot
of friends they explain to you they
hijack me from my in front of my exam
Hall they took me in the hill they tried
to kill me over there and I didn't
appear in my must first
time any if you ask the Bangladeshi
people how is America every people they
said oh there a lovely can we need to go
there if this group they introduce our
people this country is hell don't go
over there they're killing people all
over there the world like this so
whatever my friend told these groups
they are financing from the Iran turkey
China Middle East most of the country of
there and they have a big group and if
they banned last 10 years now they
because of this it was the a July it is
started the student Revolution like that
like the some the you know the job and
some uh it's called job quota like
percentage of job the Freedom Fighters
and others and government was their
favor it is on the court they started
like that the you know the protesting
like
that this is not a democratic like
movement or like that the country was
demolished and stopped they killed more
than 2,500 people they hired some of the
professional
snipers they thought if people to see
the blood and the dead body the movement
going to be first and faster and they
did
it whatever my friend said they use the
bullet from somewhere and we saw that
the bullet came from
China so there's a connection over there
after that I'd like to say something
here The the minorities what about my
friend the minorities the Christmas when
we are celebrating here Christmas such a
beautiful country because of that the
country was Jed 19 because the the
religious uh you know the the content
other things but we have very good
stability with other religious groups we
highly respect the people over there
people are living happily togethers but
is the last
Christmas the Winer people are enjoying
their Christmas 24th people was the
beaten those
group you cannot celebrate the Christmas
now most of the
Hindus they're beaten by him for their
assets burning their house more than
1,49 house was
burned there the temples are I have I'm
sorry about that I have the soft copy
because I mentioned here there's a data
you can see is not readable but you can
find I'm going to request my friends to
send all of you that the the soft copy
if there's a data over there how many
they destroyed all over the
country the women's they said they
declared the mking in the area women's
cannot go to the market we cannot do the
shopping we cannot do the like talk in
front of everyone the job are restrict
Bangladesh was the second largest
garments manufactur country all over the
world the total economy collapse and
then students the when they take up the
power they beaten the
teachers and they stopped the
examination they all over the country
they gave the auto promotion all over
the students whenever the examine
examination like you know the admission
test pass Mark was 70 the medic exam
test 70 they said okay if you have 40
you're going to pass the country is call
up the country is like the burning issue
right now there's no democracy and all
the media controlled and run by
government intelligence and government
part of the Dr unus whatever my friend
they are explained you and he own the
like the I don't have any question about
the Nobel Prize and other things like
that I'm surprised because of that in
this country he introduced those guy who
is The Mastermind the Maus he introduced
all over the country in this country and
in front of Clinton Foundation there's a
special the program and occas over there
they introduce him hey he's The
Mastermind and this is not one happening
over there it was my long-term plan
because of this movement and he's The
Mastermind here he introduced his in
front of the media all over the world
and the people of this country and how
de they
are Bangladesh AI league and the they
said the shik there's no government in
the country right now because the no
Constitution they're not following that
one they said Con should be removed
national flag should be removed they
said what about the very recently within
the last five month they change all the
you know the the the education
curriculum books like the primary
education High School colle University
they changed all the curriculum they put
their things the
Islamic like the craziest things over
there so right now we can see the media
the women's rights and that there is a
no job and they collaps everything all
the media all institution and also our
the history and the culture and
civilization whatever we have theet main
they burned all of the things very
recently they burned all our national
documents the archives and other things
so actually I going to my country like
this February 26 I'm not sure I'll be
back
again still now they are giving me
threat come to the country we need to
see you but because of the US the Visa
process is like more than like the year
because serial nobody come out of the
country they seal the airport they seal
all the borders and more than like more
than
45,000 aami League the you know the
workers they in the jail right now more
than 100,000 the case against them the
our all the most of the parliament's
members houses the burned when they the
the Shas The Prime Minister was moving
they said she leave the country she
doesn't leave the force him and she's
said if prime minister said okay they
stop them she might be do that she can
do that but she didn't do that she said
okay I need peace and she requested the
the Army police and other things and
they had a plan they said if we they
loot all the police station all over the
country and they the one place Ser guns
they locked the cops over there 15 cops
was burned over there and most of the
cops on the street they slaugh and in
front of the people over there so what
is this is this democracy is there human
rights where we are is is this really Z
right well excuse me I have to tell you
you certainly have gotten us concerned
and raised our awareness uh I there's
another gentleman that we do want to
hear from um but before I go to him can
I ask you if you take if there are any
questions for you please uh before we
give him a chance to to close out are
there questions here representative
Rollins Please Mr thank you Mr chairman
thank you for taking my question do you
have any idea what the percentage of the
people of Bangladesh belong to this
jihadist group like is it over 50 under
50% do you have any
idea what percentage of these people
belong to this type of group that's
taking control of the country thank you
representative uh actually uh this is
not a percentage very minor they have a
plan over there they have a committee
you have 68 districts and
465 station is called the upua like the
police station Bas is like that they had
a plan the every because they looting
they had looted all the weapons from the
police station and they killed the
police they said if we just you know
destroy the the the Law and Order and
they percent is not a factor every uh
they have a 30 peoples uh like the you
all of terrorist over there and they
hired some people like the young uh who
is like you know the V one on the street
like that they paid them and it was
proven they distributed drugs that
day and then you know the drug people
they can do anything and then they
distribute drugs and they HDE someone
all over the country their percentage
their quantity is going to be like below
300,000 like that that we like assuming
like this thank you for that uh and
that's a good question that
representative Rollins asks because I'm
sure we're wondering the extent of
support the new regime has that's a
great question and that's something we
want get a better understanding of other
questions representative Buddha just a
quick um you you have you know sewn this
data uh in your testimony or read this
data uh looking at this data it's very
serious condition going on there but the
data is taken out from
Wikipedia I don't think we'll be able
to uh verify the veracity of these being
published in Wikipedia is there any
other uh you know uh report or anything
published this kind of data thank you uh
Mr there's a lot of the data because of
that uh the Bangladesh the police
department right now who they controll
like that every month they have a data
how many people was injured how many
people were killed and also the human
rights in Bangladesh they have the data
before if you it is available online and
un United Nations already we appealed
over there and we already appeal the
United uh the states uh
uh uh the local uh the embassy we
applied over there we informed
everything and they can see the most of
the things the media not for Bangladeshi
media right now because media is
controlled over there data is available
if you want I can might be I might be
provide all of you all the datas
authentic that writer the BBC Voice of
America something like that and they
have already their link with this uh the
data and also one thing the Bangladesh
Hindu Foundation the world Hindu
Foundation they have the monthly report
over there so most of the thing I found
the collected from over there uh it was
mentioned and over there like it's
called the chetona uh so it is authentic
and also mightbe I can provide you more
information about that link also another
thing uh whatever you said uh uh the the
week p over there because of that the
they have a lot of hacker they already
hack the the others the government
institution like the website and things
and everything was deleted from that
because the history and the information
over there now the the Young Generation
they're trying to the you know the the
collecting all the information over
there this is the the 20124 Bangladesh
post resignation violence over there you
can see that one if you click this
link end of that link you can see more
than hundreds of the reference over
there so you might find all the
reference and there so authentic you can
find over there thank you thank you
other questions seeing No Hands thank
you for that extended testimony taking
our our
questions and uh we we'll have one more
speaker I one more pink card and that
would be for Abu mansur is Abu thank you
chairman thank you thank you again thank
you Abu yes
welcome uh Abu had five minutes down on
this final pink card and
um as I've been saying have at it we're
listen my chairman and representative I
don't want to take a lot of time I want
to go for key word could I'm sorry could
you sit down and and yes or just speak
or speak into the microphone if you
would so okay thank you so much and my
chairman and the
representative my name is Abu Manser
I'm from
Bangladesh and I want to say one thing
the minority problem is not start today
or yesterday or tomorrow it's ongoing on
problem it's never
finished sometimes going very
worse sometimes is going little
less and another key word is one
a is their
constitution and their ideology is
freedom of
religion
democracy and human rights the other all
party like a jamaat Islam BNP they all
are little bit Fanatics the jamaat Islam
is 100
Fanatics
group if if we go
1947 when he got freedom from British
rules it wasn't
Pakistan it was Hindu India and Muslim
India that's why we separated from our
own people like a bengoli
Bengal is a ethnic group it's not
Bangladeshi or not
Indian it's a group it's it's the
identity as a Bengali but we are
separated from our own identity as a
Bangladeshi like East Pakistan after
1971 because I work with minority in
hilre
area and I know in my own
experience even my oldest brother his
name is now Peter
S so when he converted from Islam to
Christianity lots of people come to kill
him because this is their holy work to
kill
him there be in heaven if someone
kill him this is their believing Faith
you cannot erase the faith because this
in your
heart not in
outside
so the someone says like the
madrasa it's actually the Islamic
Seminary that point is like all
destitute child or orphan
boy they took from the street from the
house and they train up as a
fanatism I'm sorry to say Mr Dr Muhammad
yunus he is not a fanatical people he's
not islamist he's very
secular but all of the
surround the other advisor all are
fanatics
the all people push
him and he is involved now with
fanatism with radical
people and only in banglades the a
league government trying it's trying
trying trying is has been trying for
Forever For Freedom
religion but they couldn't
we cannot release this that point even
1972 the Constitution was freedom of
religion but the one guy president aat
turn
over
1988 the state religion is the
Islam that point the minority goes to
second class citizen in this
Bangladesh and number one it's going on
from Pakistan what is
this enemy property did you heard like
that enemy
property any minority or Hindu or
Christian or Buddhist they left the
country from
Bangladesh if they go back after 10
years or 5 years they're not getting
nothing it's to be automatically by
constitutionally enemy
property thank you for all that uh
questions seeing No Hands uh I want to
thank you again for coming here I know
you had to drive a little ways and I
want to thank uh everyone representative
Khan that you had come in here those who
spoke and those who did not uh speaking
only for myself my awareness has been
very much raised I want to think I track
what's going on in the world and I I
honestly did not know much about what's
happening I'm very concerned glad you
brought this forward I can't say what's
going to happen with the resolution hr11
the uh committee will have to take it up
in exec session and and obviously have a
vote on it uh I already said if it does
move forward uh I think you'd be a
wonderful person to speak to it more so
than probably most of us so uh we will
possibly get to this to execute a week
from today and then um we'll go from
there so it with that I
will close the hearing on hr11 and we
have one more measure today we're a
little bit behind but
uh representative
Bernardi I'm sure understands that
sometimes uh we want to let folks finish
their finish what they need to uh share
with us
uh so our final measure of the day uh
house concurrent resolution hcr9 this
would go to the Senate if it gets to the
house uh a resolution urging the United
States to reject reject compliance with
the European Union's corporate
sustainability due diligence directive
and I'll be frank I I'm not really up on
the European Union's corporate
sustainability due diligence directive
uh representative but I'm sure you'll
explain that to us very interested so U
have at it well thank you chairman M and
committee and yes that's uh my goal uh
for the record I'm representative JD
Bernardi Rockingham 36 which is I live
in Southampton but also represent
Kensington Hampton Falls Newton and
plasto uh so uh with this is to
introduce H uh hcr9 which urges the US
to reject compliance with the
European corporate sustainability due to
diligence directive uh which is a
directive designed to transform business
practices across the entire world
including the US so this directive was
passed last July it becomes effective
this July and with the way the European
rules work the national governments have
to translate and put the directive into
their own National laws by July of 26
and then it becomes
effective uh for corporate compliance in
July of 27 so this is we're still in a
timely mode here um
so the
ccdd mandates that large businesses
impose ESG standards on companies
operating within their quote unquote
chain of activities regardless of
whether that chain business has
operations within the European union now
what does that mean well first off large
businesses are defined as those with a
th000
employees and
450 uh million euros in uh uh net
revenue that translates to about 500
million Us in revenue and that would
essentially mean
about 6,000 companies within
Europe but a th000 non-european
companies so what does this chain of
activities mean that means all your
supply chain also gets swept into the
mix so let's say you're a Ford Motor
Company you're likely to be one of those
1,000 us companies selling some product
in
Europe well the windshield wipers
the red tail lights on the back of the
car the uh the the knobs on the radio
probably aren't made by Ford they're
made by some supplier so those companies
also get swept into to the entire
compliance requirements of this
directive so what are those uh goals or
standards so that the European standards
on unions and Collective bargaining
health care and disease prevention
children's
education a full transition to a green
energy
economy requirements for climate
transition plans in each
Corporation reductions in water and land
usage social justice provisions and bans
on any
disinformation so this is a full
implementation of ESG Dei Paris Accord
etc etc etc all written into into the
law so businesses that failed to meet
these standards by their actions and
Reporting will face Financial penalties
of not less than 5% of their net
worldwide they call it turnover but it's
it's
essentially uh annual revenue so if
you're $100 million in sales and you
miss compliance here you're paying a $5
million fine that
year so in addition to the financial
sanctions the bill or the directive
authorizes activists groups and
individuals to also be able to sue the
various companies for alleged
damages and if a if a covered company uh
business Partners do not adhere to the
mandates the cover covered companies
must end their business relationships so
that is cut off your
suppliers or face penalties or cease
operating in the European Union so
that's the ultimate threat is you you
don't get to operate within the
EU uh beyond the beyond all these
Financial um
fines so this is likely to cause a
massive wealth transfer from the
developing to the from developed
countries to developing
countries uh as as because the
law also says that large companies have
to provide targeted and proportional
support for their small and medium-sized
business partners or suppliers that have
difficulty complying with all these
standards so again let's go back to Ford
if Ford is buying windshield wipers and
the manufacturer happens to be in
Malaysia they're going to have to go to
work with the Malaysian company to get
them up to compliance uh so no matter
where these suppliers are coming from us
or
elsewhere so the bottom line is if this
goes unaddressed by America we
effectively become a vassel state to the
Europe Union and fundamentally
transformed through corporate
coercion
now the current Trump Administration has
addressed many of these issues on a
government scale they are not addressed
for
businesses the Biden Administration when
this law was passed by the
Europeans uh indicated their support
they weren't going to stand in the way
of its compliance
as I see it if we this resolution goes
forward it will essentially uh tickle
the uh Trump Administration probably
through the Secretary of State's office
to advise Europe we are not going to
comply and if you want compliance if
you're going to demand compliance maybe
there's going to be
tariffs maybe there's going to be other
sanctions like increase your fees to
Nato maybe there's going to be uh
disruptions in supplies of American
Goods that are necessary for European
life I don't know that's going to be up
to the Secretary of State in those
discussions with the European countries
but uh the bottom line is uh I believe
it's important for America to send
a message to Europe we are not going to
comply and you're not going to force
American companies to comply with these
extremist European laws happy to answer
any
questions thank you representative uh I
know there are some questions uh before
I go to representative mandal bomb uh so
you see the EU csdd is threatening us
sovereignty yes through essentially
corporate coercion making our companies
comply with their laws which is going to
change how we do business here how long
ago is this measure passed and by the EU
you it was passed in July of of last
year
2024 and it becomes effective through
their system of how they do directives
in July of this year and then it has to
be translated into all the national laws
of each of the 26 member states in by
July of
2026 and then it becomes effective
operationally for compliance purposes in
July of
2027 thank you uh representative Mandel
bomb uh thank you Mr chairman uh
representative Bernardi I'm looking at
the American buyer association's website
and they say quote the due diligence
dtive will ultimately apply to all us
companies having the annual group-wide
revenue from the EU Market of over 450
million um Euros which is about $472
million today regardless of whether they
have any subsidiaries or branches in the
EU I'm
wondering how many US multinational
companies would fall into that category
of having group-wide revenue of over 450
million euros
um yeah so the the estimated number is
about a th000 American companies and
6,000 European companies but again
that's the large companies and it also
sweeps in all those suppliers so that
little supplier making that little red
tailight in the back of your car you
know they may have uh a $3
million a year uh company they're going
to be swept into so that's why the ABA
is saying this is going to Encompass the
most of the US
economy representative
F thank you so um I did read the uh the
csdd um I would urge my fellow committee
members to do so as well there's some
there's the whole thing and then there's
very concise information available um so
this is applies to private companies
doing business in the European Union so
is the goal here to for the government
to tell private businesses not to comply
because I mean this is on the businesses
to advance their to comply or to you
know cease doing business in the EU so
is your goal for the United States to
direct all applicable businesses not to
comply with this
directive if an American Business wanted
to comply with this type of directive on
their own valtion you know that's their
business however uh this
particular uh resolution is to have the
US government tell European authorities
we you cannot mandate
your vision of how companies should
operate in the United
States follow
up but
you so I mean it is essentially of Their
Own ition they have the option to uh you
know they could pay these fees or they
could not do business in the European
Union but uh you don't think that it's
the right of the EU to determine what
kind of companies are allowed to do
business or for any um you know body
like the United States for example you
don't think that the United States is
allowed to set regulations for what kind
of companies are allowed to do business
here uh this bill doesn't do anything
about setting requirements for us
businesses doing business in Europe we
essentially have a uh a a a capitalist
country where we have regulations on
safety and and um uh uh those types of
things but this is this is policy
directives that are well beyond the
normal scope of doing business so again
if a company is in favor of these kinds
of uh activities they can sign up and
they can run ESG programs on their own
and Dei programs they can do whatever
they want or they can or or or
essentially what this what this uh
European law says if you don't want to
comply with those kind of things and you
don't like it you can't can't do any
business here well you
know I don't I don't think that's
appropriate I'm Mr chairman I just have
another followup sure thank you um so it
sounds like from what you just said that
your issue is more with the substance of
the directive but uh if it's uh low or
appropriate for a body to set
regulations in general for the kinds of
companies that are allowed to operate
within that uh that body why is that not
corporate
coercion I okay the the way most of our
regulatory structures work uh is is we
we come up with agreements like and we
have uh un or a similar uh
um or organizations that will set these
are the rules of the road that we're
going to use internationally for air
traffic these are the rules of the road
that we're going to use for transporting
packages these are the rules of the road
that we're going to use safety wise for
uh nuclear materials whatever so we have
a system that that has worked in where
all comp uh countries get together and
and agree on standards of how they're
going to do business this is the
European Union saying the heck with the
rest of the world you're going to do it
our way and that's
unacceptable other questions
representative Hemingway thank you Mr
chairman thank you representative taking
my question
so I did I did some research on
this probably last year year before as
this was
developing so BAS Bally essentially my
understanding of this ESG uh which is
environmental social and governance um
so this is going to be the standard for
determining whether a business can do
business with another person or another
entity um the problem with that is that
if you don't comply with ESG standards a
company will not be able to get a loan
correct correct uh and uh as I continue
Mr chairman um here we go yeah the so in
a sense
a bank a financial institution or
another manufacturer could determine who
they want to do business with which they
can do anyway but they would have to
follow ESG those three those three thing
things that if they were not environment
environmentally sound and and didn't do
things to protect their environment they
weren't socially uh inclusive of of all
the organizations and the governance of
of uh fair and Equity uh I think it was
was like
uh pay managers pay and and you know uh
equal pay equal work equal everything so
those items and if I if I've looked
further in
Japan uh China they are already doing
this on a lower scale to the people
there they are not able to if you don't
follow those those guidance they're not
able to get a loan for a house or or
their job is in Jeopardy because they're
not following those rules is that
correct that is correct if in China if
you don't follow the rules you you don't
get to buy the bus token to drive to get
to work I I mean it's it's that simple I
mean it's control
mechanism uh an ultimate control
mechanism representative Hemingway so
kudos for doing some Advanced due
diligence uh you may have positioned
yourself to do a committee report I
don't know uh but uh good on you for
that um this screams for Commerce
Committee uh as I look at this language
uh th the folks in Commerce I think
would uh drill down and have questions
similar to what representative Hemingway
has already asked uh but we we tend to
do resolutions here and this is a
certainly
resolution um a concurrent resolution my
question are you concerned about
retaliation if if uh if
the desire of this resolution were to be
put into practice by the current
Administration uh and I think you
mentioned tariffs we hearing a lot about
tariffs uh are you concerned about
retaliation by the EU if if we move
forward with this type of
resistance well I I I think our response
would be perceived as retaliation to
what they're trying to do to us they
struck first with this and and if we say
no you know yeah we th this we either
get down on our knees and comply or we
say no and you know we're we're going to
get into a heated discussion on what the
consequences of this kind of activity
are
um yes I mean that's that's where this
goes potentially
uh representative
cyber um I have um two I have two small
questions but I think the first one
really is based off of you know first of
all how is this different from the
tariffs that are on the table right now
for us to force other countries
essentially to
pay for in products being
shipped how is this difference
I guess um it would it be con I mean to
me that would be just as much a coercion
as this would
be well I think uh where I've heard
discussions of tariffs is against Mexico
and China for you know let's you stop
your drug trade stop your fentel
processing coming in or you know there's
going to be compliance there's going to
be retaliation that way against your
government so in those types of
situations we're defining an ill that
we're saying we want you to stop and if
you don't we're going to put a tariff on
you this you could say this is this is
similar but uh uh it hasn't started yet
this is going to happen if we don't bow
down and in additionally have all our
large companies sweep in all our small
suppliers to to do this kind of
compliance
work just my one extra question sure
thank you um the one other one thing I
wanted to say was in regards to um cuz I
I kind of wanted to piggy back off what
Lily had said before in regards to um
the so it seems like though we're
entering into this or just agreeing with
this or whatever it's a compliance
situation allowing for companies to make
compliance if we repeal this companies
who still want to do business
that qualify for it that still want to
do business with the EU or you know some
we might have that already are
previously complying now might not be
able to do that because we're not
entering into this agreement I mean
that's what it looks like to me no no no
if corporations can conduct business
however they want to if they want to
employ ESG Dei standards and whatnot
they want to have uh a a vast amount of
uh uh compliance with uh Green New Deal
technology if that's what they want as
part of how they're going to run their
business they can do that on their own
and they're not forbidden for from
having any conducting business in in
Europe what what the European law says
is if you don't comply with our vision
of those items you can't do business in
Europe or we're going to find the heck
out of
you represent Manion thank you Mr chair
thanks for taking my question so uh when
you're talking about like the smaller uh
manufacturers that may be providing to
the larger International corporations it
could be that this ends up being a um
would you would you would you agree that
it's picking winners and losers where
the smaller companies that could not
compete to meet these regulatory
standards would just go entirely out of
business and the only things left would
be molter International corporations
that's possible it's going to force uh
you know compliance in that direction so
if they can't if if a smaller uh company
can't comply and they don't get the
quote unquote help that they're supposed
to from the large corporation by this uh
directive yeah their their Market size
would shrink and potentially that could
force them out of
business representative Mandel bom thank
you Mr chairman um
so I'm just trying to understand what
the core issue is is it about the
csdd having the ability to sue companies
for alleged damages or is it more about
what this law is
asking potentially us you know
multinational corporations to do like is
it about this specific actions that
they're asking for well the directive
basically says if you want to do
business in Europe you must comply so so
it's it's a doing business issue and if
you still do business in Europe or try
to do business in Europe and don't
comply you will be fined and and
ultimately if you don't comply then we
will shut the door you can't come
in follow up thank you Mr chairman
so is this just to clarify is this about
the issue of compliance in general or
Are there specific things that this law
is mandating that you're opposed to it's
it's compliance with the package of
requirements that they've they've
embedded in the directive I summarize
them there but if you go into the
directive this is a large laundry list
and some of them you know you may say
hey this is great I I'm I'm all for you
know this and others of them you'd say
no I don't and it's inappropriate for
the Europeans to pick the policies that
us Corporation should be adopting it's
up to us corporations to do that you
know they're when they make a product
and offer it you
know uh
rep representative
gagy thank you Mr chairman see if I get
this right because I
what they're proposing the EU is my way
or the highway is that correct I would
say that's a nice shorthand okay follow
up follow up not withstanding that we
bailed them out twice in the last
century could it also be said that you
want to play that game we can play that
game you guys pay for all your defenses
from from now on how's that that as I
indicated I would expect if the US
government Secretary of State's office
agrees that this is inappropriate to
force this kind of compliance on us
companies they can they have several
arrows in the quiver one could be
tariffs one could be you're paying for
all of NATO or we're we're leaving uh or
uh you need certain special components
that are only made and manufactured in
the US we're not selling them to you you
know we can we can play a counter game
if they want to do
that represent man uh thanks for taking
my question uh the outcome of all of
this would be increased prices on the
end consumer you would you say that if
if this continues yes
my my guess
is a solid posture against this by the
United States is going to force the
European Union to re address this
directive it barely passed I mean if you
follow the European Politics on this
issue those in power in the European
Parliament when this passed tended to
be strongly on the
left they saw the elections were
swinging against them they expected that
in the next round of elections they
would be losing many seats so they
basically said if we're going to do this
kind of stuff we got to do it
now the European parliament's changing
and the European Parliament could very
well
uh you know renig on this change changed
this law there's many particularly in
the Eastern block uh of of the European
Union the polands the Czech republics
and whatnot I just said we don't like
this at all and they voted very strongly
against
it uh representative Bernardi you
anticipated my qu you already answered
the question I was going to ask and that
had to do with how agile how Nimble is
the EU in terms of changing course so
you ahead of me in this obviously ahead
of most of us so you said this passed
narrowly so do you know or perhaps
someone perhaps repres of Hemingway
knows I do you know um what the uh what
the process is or or the timeline for
change because I know as you said the
eu's uh makeup is is changing U how soon
could they make a change or do you
know well in the next in the next
Parliament they could bring up a
resolution and and to change compliance
with us they could say they could change
the compliance say oh we're going to
keep this but it's only going to apply
to European companies okay then we have
no no problem right it's when they want
to make it comply to the world they want
to rule the world you know that that's
that's the issue so uh but timing wise
um
the next parliaments are is is are are
starting to meet now you know the same
as same as our
Congress so representative Bernard are
you looking to interfere in EU Affairs
uh quite clearly I'm I'm asking the
United States to tell Europe you cannot
tell our companies how to
operate okay other questions
representative
F oh yes um so it's
it's not specifically us companies it's
any companies across the world that have
more than 150 or 450 million euros in
Revenue coming from the European Union
um so it's it's not targeted I just
don't understand how is it appropriate
for the US government to interfere
with private
businesses and the European Union
I think it's the other way around it's
inappropriate for the European
businesses to interfere with American
companies or any international company
for that matter but I I'm mostly
concerned with American
companies followup followup uh but
that's not what this law is doing this
would insert the US government into
these relationships between private
businesses and the European Union no
this directive asked the US government
to tell the European authorities we
don't want you mandating these
requirements on American
businesses representative Lloyd thank
you Mr chairman and thank you for taking
my question um so I guess my concern
here would be a a precedent um being
broken or being set where are you at all
concerned about what this might mean if
the US has a specific regulation or
requirement to operate businesses for
for foreign um com foreign companies
foreign owned companies to have
businesses here what that would mean for
those businesses because we may have
more strict or stringent requirements or
regulations where another organization
does
not uh okay I'm trying I'm trying to get
wrap my head around that so again most
of
uh international trade is are the you
know the practices are governed by uh by
in
by various commissions and committees L
often times under the under the
supervision of the UN setting ultimate
standards I mean I could see if the
United States
says uh we are no long longer going to
accept any productss in the United
States made with slave
labor you know that would be interfering
with the business practices of China
that would but should we and could we do
that yes we can so if that's a if that's
an unacceptable precedent I I would
accept
that representative fos um well speaking
of precedent how is this different than
the uh Tick Tock band which was just
held as constitutional by the Supreme
Court is that
not another example of the US already
having set
regulations first off there wasn't a Tik
Tock ban what there was was a
requirement that Tik tock not be owned
by the Communist Party of
China the ownership structure of Tik
tock goes straight back to the CCP so
the the ban was Tik Tock you can operate
but you have to divest your ownership
from the CCP so that's what's going on
in fact the the ability to operate now
has been extended to allow the company
to find a a an an ownership structure
that's not tied to the Communist
Party followup followup um to be clear I
was using Tik Tok band colloquially I'm
familiar with the law um so bik dance
the owner of Tik Tok was given the
option of selling to a US company how is
that different than companies being
given the option of complying with this
existing law or not doing business in
the United
States or not doing business in the
European Union not doing business in the
United States is obviously what happened
with this law for bite
dance I I think the issue is what are
the standards and so the US is is is and
every country can do this uh you set
standards of minimum compliance that you
want to see in in uh in Commerce so we
set a standard that we don't want uh
social media companies to be owned by
the Communist Party of China that's the
standard
so the Europeans Set uh a massive number
of Standards uh many of which uh most of
the United States populations finds
disagreeable and sent that message loud
and clear in the last
election
uh
so I mean I think I think that's the
fundamental
issue so up so you said when you started
out your answer though that a country
has the ability to set
requirements so it sounds like you agree
that the European Union has the the
right to set requirements I absolutely
agree they can set these standards and
they can they can say eventually uh
we're not going to uh you know allow any
American companies to uh do business
here they can do that they can close
their doors they have that
right does anyone else have any a hand
up before I go back to representative F
just just to be
fair yeah I I'm turning you you have the
same question you said or oh maybe not I
feel like I'm
following uh go ahead rip some
F Well um if you agree that it's fine
for businesses and for for the EU to do
that what's the issue the
standards so just to call it spade a
spade your issue is with the
ideological bent of the
standards if the European Union passed a
directive saying we are not going to
accept any products made with slave
labor I don't think I or most of the
people in the United States would have
any concern with that but if
passed this directive which has a vast
list of Standards many of
which most people in the United States
do not agree with yes I do have an issue
with
that representative mandal bomb did you
want to ask something um well I did just
kind of want to want to build on
representative F's question and a
question I had asked earlier which I
feel like I received a contradictory
answer to so which pieces of this law
specifically do you find
objectionable pieces of the the the core
of the directive goes to the standards
that the Europeans are trying to impose
on all companies of size so it is that
laundry list of
Standards I mean I the some of them I
can go down the list and say oh that's
nice and I have no issue with that but
the real issue is in aggregate that list
is an unacceptable
list the current Administration has
already said many of the things that are
identified there are unacceptable and
are not going to be done in the US
government anymore yet the Europeans are
trying to back door into United States
through this this compliance
requirements on
corporations that's what I'm object
objecting to
so that goes back to my initial question
right up front about sovereignty you see
this as a sovereignty issue it is a
sovereignty issue yes okay other
questions uh representative
Lloyd thank you Mr chairman and thank
you again for taking my question um so I
guess are you aware of this being a
capitalist Society um are you aware of
the most recent reports that show that
corporate uh sustainability is actually
more profitable for
businesses I'm I'm not aware of any
particular report on that I would say
yes sustainability is always you know a
good thing you want your company to to
uh continue on but defining what the
issues are to ensure sustainability I
think there's tremendous differences of
opinion on what those what constitutes
that that those
standards I see hand representative
mandal B uh thank you Mr chairman um I
have a question and then a request if I
may so I'm I just I'm struggling with
the idea that members of the European
Union are not allowed to set their own
standards they are so then what's the
concern they're saying these are the
standards we're talking about private
businesses they
can you know choose to engage with that
or not not and I mean you you brought up
the example that if we were to say that
we are not going to import any Goods
produced with slave
labor why is that more acceptable than
for instance saying that we you know the
European union doesn't want any Goods
that are produced in places that don't
have safe working conditions or or
reasonal limitation of working
hours that's not what this does that's
I'm I'm looking at it right now that may
be one and as I indicated there in in
that large basket of Standards you may
look at some of them and say yeah I that
one that one's a good one let's pick
that good one out and no it's it's it's
the entire basket is you have to comply
with and there are many items in there
that are unacceptable and the American
people don't agree with so the Europeans
can set the requirements for European
companies to comply with that that's
fine but they don't have the right well
they they do have the right to tell us
that if we want to do business there but
we have the right to say we're not going
to do it that's the Counterpoint right I
and I think that's what representative
fos was saying there's a choice there um
and that's the purpose of the resolution
is for us to say we don't agree with
your basket of Standards we are not
going to require American companies to
do that and if you are going to take
action against American companies you
can expect counter action against
European companies and European uh
governments for that kind of
behavior what you just said I think
captures what you're trying to do very
well that that was well stated I'm
starting to get it better repr manal Bon
you have your hand up sure um I just had
a followup so
[Music]
um I'm I'm struggling a bit with this
idea it's the package but you know
countries can put in standards that they
want and I just
um I would so this is more of a
statement or a request than a question
but I would find it useful if you could
go through this list of conditions and
Mark which ones you find acceptable and
and which ones you think the the US
should not support
I that's that's a large task that's a
big list uh so I
mean I can tell
you there's some of them right away that
I have absolutely no agreement with um
Europeans shouldn't be setting Union uh
collective bargaining requirements for
the for the United States they shouldn't
be requiring ESG and Dei requirements
and our current Administration has said
we're not going to do that in the
government already that is already a
policy of the United States on a
government level
so why the Europeans should be able to
force that on us
companies doesn't make any sense so
those those are three right off the
top other questions representative
benett thank you for um letting me ask a
question question so I'm going to chime
in here um I'm thinking
about uh this whole
thing as you said um in the recent we
did have recently voted and so if we
complied with this do you think that
there would be a lot of companies that
might uh have
employees that would say if you do this
we're not going to work for your company
anymore do you think Americans would
have that resolve after all we've been
through or do you think they just just
go ahead and do it because they want to
work and they need a
paycheck well some yeah that's a mixed
bag I mean some some people you when
they were certain requirements came into
the I guess the
trying to get an example in my head and
so the so if in in the covid era Thou
shalt take the the jab or not if you
want to work here right so there were
people that said no I'm not going to do
it and they've had to leave the
company uh there are some companies
where had enough people stand up and say
no and the company changes the
policy it's it it yes the answer is yes
all of the above can happen
other
questions seeing none I have no other
pink cards I I wish there was uh another
one more pink card to someone to speak
against we have to play the role of uh
in the absence of uh anybody else
opposing the bill to to uh do our due
diligence and pepper you like we have
been and I think there's been some
really good questions uh and I I I thank
the committee for hanging in there and
and and thank you ups and Bernard for
hanging in there too uh with that with
no other the pink cards and no one else
here I will close the hearing on
hcr9 so this committee will reconvene a
week from today we'll have some more
hearings in the morning uh we cancelled
or postponed our two exec exec items to
the Future uh I'm going to get with a
ranking member uh she oh good next week
we're going to do those next week uh you
and I will chat in just a few minutes
and uh so we we will work on an exact
session in fact it's already been uh
calendared or published uh all the all
the measures that we heard through this
one will be on there to be exact whether
we get to
so uh thank you all for your time and
we'll U we'll see everybody down the
road representative Lin gone uh oh he's
gone okay